contenu à interpeller le gouvernement
sur ce qui se jouait au Sénat et aussi
sur le fait qu'il fallait qu'ils
entendent les gens qui se mobilisaient
dans la rue écoutez un extrait de la
réponse de la première ministre
soir l'interfedicale a demandé à être
reçu le gouvernement est toujours prêt
et ouvert au dialogue comme il l'a
montré ces derniers mois si les
organisations syndicales souhaitent
évoquer certains points particuliers la
porte du ministre du Travail Olivier du
soft reste toujours ouverte car je le
rappelle c'est bien dans la concertation
et le dialogue que ce texte a été
construit
et vous l'avez dit Quentin les sénateurs
viennent de commencer l'examen de
l'article 7 article névralgique de ce
projet de loi et il y a eu une soirée
très mouvementée une nuit très de
mouvement théière
jusqu'à 3h30 du matin nous étions en
direct pour tout vivre effectivement
l'examen de l'article 7 il a commencé
hier vers 19h en séance mais ça c'est
véritablement agité autour de une heure
et demie du matin point de départ le
moment où Bruno retaille au chef de fil
des LR du Sénat enclenche l'article 38
du Règlement du Sénat un article qui
vient contraindre le nombre de prises de
parole sur chacun de manque là à ce
moment la gauche dénonce l'utilisation
de cet article 38 dit que c'est un
scandale qu'il y a un bayonnement de
l'opposition sénatoriale et dans le même
temps on voit le rapporteur de la
branche vieillesse René Paul Savary qui
annonce une suspension de séance pour la
réunion de la commission des affaires
sociales hier soir une réunion qui dure
quelques minutes et où l'on apprend que
ce dépose une nouvelle version de
l'article 7 sur les 64 ans qu'est-ce que
ça signifie à ce moment-là dans
l'hémicycle ça signifie et il est à peu
près 1h30 2h du matin ça signifie que
1000 amendements de la gauche
sénatoriale tombe ne peuvent plus être
examinés c'est donc un coup dur pour la
gauche du matériel qui vous laisse
opposer au texte mais que la droite
assume complètement vous l'en répondre à
l'obstruction à un quel estime de
l'obstruction de la part de la gauche
sauf que et bien ça ne s'arrête pas là
on voit la soirée qui continue de
nouvelles suspensions et la gauche
notorielle qui avait préparé des
milliers de sous amendements à cet
amendement ça varie pour également
pouvoir reprendre la parole dans ce qui
se joue à ce moment-là on assiste alors
à une nouvelle suspension de séance de
45 minutes et au retour d'une réunion de
la commission des affaires sociales on
apprend que c'est sous amendements de la
gauche ont tous été jugés ils recevable
par le Sénat et la gauche qui à ce
moment-là décide de quitter l'hémicycle
dénonce un nouveau
et décide de ne plus siéger dans la
suite des débats et donc c'est sur ce
moment là que c'est son suspendu les
débats à 3h30 du matin hier et il reste
maintenant à peu près 75 amendements qui
restent à examiner sur cet article 7 sur
les 64 ans puisque cet article n'a
toujours pas été fini d'être examiné il
y aura donc peut-être un vote
aujourd'hui dans les prochaines heures
de la soirée mais donc il reste des
amendements à examiner de tout bord
confondu ce sont 75 amendements qui ont
été retenus à la fois des bancs DLR des
bancs même des communistes donc on va
voir si ce débat peut reprendre
sereinement ou si la gauche dénonce
toujours les conditions de cinéma
surtout que dernière information Tam le
la majorité de la droite et du centre a
décidé d'utiliser un autre article du
règlement ça a été décidé ce matin en
conférence des présidents l'article 42
qui va limiter les prises de parole au
prorata de l'importance des groupes
politiques dans l'hémicycle Tam merci
merci beaucoup
Valentin et oui on le voit la droite et
la majorité sénatoriale elle sort toutes
les armes pour raccourcir le débat on va
rejoindre Alexandre Poussard celle des
conférences qui se trouvent avec
Pierre-Antoine Lévy et oui
Pierre-Antoine Lévy on est à quelques
secondes la reprise des débats ici au
Sénat sur la réforme de retraite donc
quel état d'esprit sont les sénateurs
centrist c'est ce que vous dites oui il
faut accélérer les débats quitte à
utiliser des outils du règlement pour
bâillonner la gauche alors je trouve que
vous allez dur en disant qu'on Bayonne
on les a écouté
pas chiant on a écouté des milliers
d'interventions depuis jeudi dernier
quand même et sur l'article 7 on a
écouté 54 prises de parole plus 70
articles identiques qui ont été
présentés intégralement par tous les
sénateurs socialistes écologistes et
communistes donc on a Bayonne les
personnes et un moment donné il faut
qu'on accélère parce que qu'est-ce
qu'attendait français également ils ont
manifesté ils attendent aussi que le
Sénat vote un texte or il reste encore
il reste encore 2300 amendements on en a
étudié 1500 et aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
passe maintenant à la vitesse supérieure
et les présidents retaillaux au
président de Marseille et le président
expliquer qu'il y avait des articles de
disposition et si la gauche continue à
faire de l'obstruction les mettra en
application donc la gauche c'était
préparée puisque quand même 3000
amendements de sous-amendement sortir
une demi-heure ou doutez bien quand même
que ils étaient préparés ils avaient
déjà préparé leurs armes donc bien sûr
qu'il faut continuer il faut qu'on
examine les textes parce que au-delà de
l'article 7 il y a des avancées très
notable pour les petites retraites pour
les femmes notamment avec la surcotte et
il faut qu'on les examine alors
justement on va arriver à la fin de
l'examen de cet article 7 qui reste
quand même des amendements à discuter
sur cette article 7 qui reporte l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
et ce qu'il faut le voter tel quel cet
article 7 ou on peut encore l'améliorer
alors cet article 7 on peut l'améliorer
vous avez noté que parce qu'il me
concerne je me suis abstenu sur la
suppression d'article 7 tout simplement
parce que ce qui me concerne je pensais
qu'il fallait aller plus loin sur la
pénibilité mais il faut qu'on nous
votion une réforme qui servait à quelque
chose et qui donne les moyens financiers
surtout de dans les années 2030 d'ici
2030 de régler une partie du déficit
même si on sait il reviendra dans
quelques années donc en ce qui me
concerne je me suis abstenu je vais
m'abstiendrai certainement sur l'article
7 ce qui veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
voter la réforme voilà mais il faut
accélérer parce qu'il y a encore une
fois des des avancées notables et
notamment sur les petites pensions
puisque nous avons nous pensons au petit
retraites et si on veut avoir une chance
de pouvoir les augmenter au mois de
septembre comme ça a été évoqué il faut
qu'on accélère le texte donc cet article
7 c'est l'article symbole de la gauche
mais il y avait un article je rappelle
dans cette loi il faut qu'on avance et
qu'on vote le texte si on peut juste
pour finir sur cette article 7 vous êtes
absolu sur sa suppression car vous êtes
mal à l'aise quand vous entendez le
mécontentement peut-être dans votre
circonscription alors mais j'écoute pas
dans ma circonscription j'écoute la
France aujourd'hui effectivement on ne
peut pas ignorer ce qui se dit dans la
rue mais ce qu'il faut que les gens
sachent aussi c'est que quand on est
parlementaire on doit être responsable
et voter des lois qui servent à quelque
chose aujourd'hui nous votons une loi
nous sommes là pour examiner nos lois
qui est là pour sauver notre régime de
retraite par répartition il y a deux
chocs de vous avez deux affrontements un
affrontement de la gauche contre la
droite nous pour nous notre nos
marqueurs centrist et nous les avons
fait entendre dans le cadre de la
commission mais aujourd'hui il faut
écouter la rue bien évidemment mais on
peut pas non plus faire des lois en
fonction de la rue on est là aussi pour
adapter et surtout écouter ce qui se dit
mais il faut que les gens sachent quand
même que cette retraite cette réforme
des retraites elle doit être faite elle
doit on doit la voter et on doit sauver
notre régime de retraite tout simplement
parce que on peut pas dire aux gens dans
10 ans ou dans 15 ans on va où baisser
vos pensions parce qu'on n'a pas été
responsable pour voter la réforme merci
beaucoup Pierre Antoine Lévy pour votre
réaction votre intervention à quelques
secondes de la reprise de ces débats sur
la réforme des retraites ici au Sénat on
va retourner en tribune de l'hémicycle
du Sénat ou Quentin vous allez suivre ce
soir et cette nuit c'est débat sur la
forme des retraites voilà tout à fait
Alex alors que la séance vient de
reprendre à l'instant c'est
effectivement un rappel au règlement de
Pierre Laurent qui est en cours on
retourne dans l'hémistique en direct
cette nuit pour accélérer la clôture
prioritaire des débats sur l'article 7
et sur le projet de loi retraite la
commission des affaires sociales a
invoqué l'article 44 bis du règlement
pour déclarer irrecevable plusieurs
centaines de sous amendements qui ont
été déposés après la réécriture de
l'article 7 qui sont devenus subitement
irresovables alors que les amendements
qu'il reproduisaient avec eux étaient
déclarés recevables par la même
commission la présidente de roche sur la
figure au compte-rendu a d'ailleurs
reconnu qu'il s'agissait des mêmes
amendements mais le vice-président
karucci nous a en quelque sorte livré
l'explication de texte
à partir du moment où l'article réécrit
était devenu un amendement cela rendait
soi-disant impossible de le sous-amender
en le on contestant le sens
effectivement le règlement 40 bis rend
impossible au dépôt d'un sous amendement
qui soit contraire à l'amendement auquel
il s'applique mais achète en
l'occurrence un détournement de sens du
règlement car si nous acceptons cette
interprétation il suffit alors de
transformer un article entier et ça a
été le cas cette nuit on en abondement
on le réécrivant pour le rendre
inabondable c'est-à-dire l'article qui
est lui-même
constitutionnellement amandables et
contestable devient par le jeu d'une
réécriture en amendement un article
inammendable c'est donc une atteinte de
fait à la capacité et au droit
constitutionnels d'amendements des
parlementaires il faut donc être
extrêmement vigilant mes chers collègues
vers sur ce précédent car c'est un
précédent qui a été créé et qui ouvre la
porte à toutes les manipulations contre
le droit d'amendement jeudi au
républicains
assumer le vote du coup
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mon rappel
au règlement se fonde sur l'article 44
de la Constitution les membres du
Parlement et le gouvernement ont le
droit d'amendement cette nuit en effet
des sous amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables sans même avoir été examiné
en commission de la veux même de sa
présidence nombre des notes portées sur
des précisions techniques manifestement
parfaitement recevable ce droit
inaliénable d'amendement a été utilisé
par la commission pour reformuler
l'article 7 dans une version quasi
identique au texte originel dans le seul
but de faire disparaître les amendements
des groupes de gauche qui relaient ici
les préoccupations de nos concitoyens
mobilisés très massivement encore hier
ces amendements portés par exemple sur
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
sur le report de l'âge légal de départ
en retraite ces sujets que vous nous
disiez vouloir débattre que vraiment
entendu ici sur l'examen de ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale mais ce qui se
passe ici même au Sénat et l'autre face
d'une même pièce empêcher le travail
parlementaire sur ce texte et cela non
non pas le Sénat où est passé la sagesse
que vous convoquez régulièrement
où est la rigueur légendaire du Sénat
disparu dans de basses manœuvres qui
n'effaceront pas nous vous le disons mes
chers collègues la détermination du
peuple français a rejeté cette réforme
et cette très très mauvaise réforme
merci chers collègues monsieur gay
pour un rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article
je m'exprime devant vous avec solanité
mes chers collègues et une colère froide
nos débats sont très suivis à
l'extérieur beaucoup nous ont dit qu'il
comptait sur nous tout et tous pour
échanger avoir un débat de fond et pour
notre paragu à gauche nous y opposer
pour y faire un chèque car nous sommes
dans l'opposition depuis jeudi nous
pensons que nous faisons la politique en
ayant un débat argumenté précisé
documenté ce qui est bien le rôle du
Parlement tant que nous sommes pas
passés à la Sixième République et
changer de constitution chaque
parlementaire a le droit de déposer un
amendement et de le défendre même si la
droite accusait la gauche d'une
obstruction cordiale et qu'en réponse
nous vous renvoyons celle d'une
obstruction
silencieuse nous avons aussi dans le
débat
celui que nous avons eu dimanche projet
comme projet répartition contre
capitalisation a été utile je le pense
qui peut dire ici que nous avons perdu
du temps c'est pour ça que hier nous
avons été très surpris qu'au moment
d'arriver au cœur du projet vous
déclenchiez une série d'articles de
règlement pour la première fois
l'arthrite 38 reste régnant la parole
puis la réécriture de l'article 7
rendant innamendable cet article et
enfin déclarant nos amendements devenus
sous amendements
anticonstitutionnel pour question
d'égalité alors qu'une demi-heure avant
il ne l'était pas sans pourvoir nous
l'expliquer si on y rajoute les
décisions pris ce matin avec de
nouvelles dispositions pour réduire une
nouvelle fois le temps de parole c'est
un coup de force coup de force certes
permis par le règlement mais le
règlement n'est que là pour organiser
notre vie commune lorsqu'on l'utilise
pour régler une question politique c'est
que nous sommes au bord d'une crise
démocratique en fait l'utilisation de
toutes ces règles prouve votre fébrilité
et montrent que vous avez besoin
d'autoritarisme pour établir votre
autorité politique vous avez perdu et
vous le savez vous êtes minoritaire
alors que chacun sera sur ici que celles
et ceux qui luttent dehors nous restons
utile et déterminés ici comme samedi
prochain pour le retrait de ce projet
monsieur Savoldelli
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ceci est un rappel au
règlement même arctique 44 bis en effet
le recours exceptionnel exceptionnel à
l'article 38 du Règlement Intérieur et
cela en pleine nuit le jour même d'une
mobilisation historique de grande
ampleur contre cette réforme des
retraites écrit main dans la main avec
le gouvernement nous sommes constitués
une attaque en règle et particulièrement
grave de notre démocratie parlementaire
cet article clôture en effet un débat
parlementaire d'une façon qui ne Nort
pas notre institution j'ai bien entendu
madame la Première ministre tout à
l'heure qui a invoquait la séparation
des pouvoirs pourtant nous ne pouvons
que constater la constitution ou du
moins le renforcement de ce bloc de
droit libéral comme une sorte de
remaniement ministériel qui annoncerait
de futurs changements institutionnels
mais dans quel régime politique nous
trouvons nous ces pratiques sont
honteuses parce que si vous êtes en
train de préparer en douce encore une
fois un changement institutionnel
synonyme d'un nouveau régime politique
et bien dites le nous et vous n'ignorez
pas vous ignorez avec arrogance et
déconsidérations la colère des
Françaises et les Français et c'est
pourtant difficile de ne pas voir que
personne ne veut perdre ses deux plus
belles années de retraite pour prendre
deux années de travail les plus
difficiles le même jour de la journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes vous apprêtez à faire passer
en force par un coup de force
institutionnel un article l'article 7
qui pénalisera en premier lieu les
femmes et vous le savez et là je voulais
m'adresser à monsieur le président
Gérard Larcher qu'il m'écoute monsieur
le président Gérard Larcher dans la nuit
d'hier vous avez été davantage le
président des LR que le président du
Sénat en se soumettant en se soumettant
à l'agenda du gouvernement avec cet
article 38 article réclamé par le
président rotaïo et applaudi par les
centristes monsieur le Président Larcher
vous décrétabilisez notre institution et
le travail Parlement aire je m'adrose
donc à ce nouveau blog de droit merci
chers soyez raisonnable soirée pour
retirer cette réforme merci
la parole était président
merci merci monsieur le Président
rappelle au Règlement sur la base de la
décision du 11 juin 2015 du Conseil
constitutionnel sur le caractère
effectif de l'exercice du droit
d'amendement et les exigences de clarté
de sincérité du débat parlementaire en
effet ça ça vient encore et d'être
appelé plusieurs éléments ont été
particulièrement problématiques lors de
la dernière séance de notre assemblée ou
araignée c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
une très grande confusion la liste est
donc et mes collègues poursuivrons sur
le le la liste des irrigarités la
commission notamment n'a pas réellement
examiné les sous amendements de la vue
même de la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales a
déclaré ne pas avoir examiné certains
sous amendements comme La Teste
compte-rendu analytique de la séance à
sa page 69 mais a ensuite déclaré y
recevable c'est même sous amendements
pour ensuite déclarer les avoir examinés
ce qui est matériellement impossible la
Commission n'a pas cité le bon fondement
pour déclarer les sous amendements
irrecevables en raison de leur
soi-disant contradiction avec
l'amendement de réécriture c'est
l'article 44 bis 3 pour seul fondement
qui a été cité alors en Corée du être
invoqué l'article 44 bis Ali à neuf
invoquant les motifs prévus à l'article
44 bis Alina 4 la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales a omis
des informations elle n'a cité aucun
article du règlement pour déclarer les
sous-amendements d'exception de
différents métiers irrecevable alors
qu'elle aurait dûment énoncer qu'elle se
fondait sur lactique 44 bis alien A10
elle a également anticipé la décision du
Sénat en déclarant y recevable ses
amendements alors qu'elle a été fondée
qu'à demander que le Sénat se prononce
sur leur seul irrévassable il
recevabilité enfin la présidence de
séance n'a pas éclairci la procédure ni
garantit la clarté la sincérité des
débats la distinction entre les deux
formes d'irrégularité et leur fondement
réglementaire n'a pas non plus été
spécifié par la présidence il aurait été
il aurait été pardon souhaitable qu'il
précise les différents fondements et les
amendements concernés enfin certains
sous amendements ont finalement été
discutés en séance sans être distribué
afin que les sénateurs puissent s'en
saisir ils ont été rejetés par le Sénat
pour finalement merci être déclaré il
recevable impossible c'est le cas du
sous-amendement 4766
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article et sur la même décision du 11
juin 2015 du Conseil constitutionnel sur
les exigences de clarté et de sincérité
des débats parlementaires l'organisation
de la séance la nuit dernière à nuit à
la
qui s'est déroulé dans la confusion
absolue à perturber la clarté des débats
les droits ouverts au sénateur par le
règlement intérieur n'ont pas été
respectées la séance a refusé des
rappels au règlement en parfaite
contradiction avec l'article 36 alinéa 3
du règlement qui disposent pourtant que
la parole est accordée sur le champ à
tous sénateurs qu'il a demandé pour un
rappel au règlement de plus les
sénateurs ont dû voter dans la
précipitation et la confusion sur une
motion qu'il n'avait pas sous les yeux
la version papier de la motion tendance
et l'exception 10 recevabilité n'a pas
été distribué au sénateur avant le vote
la volonté de patient en force n'excuse
n'excuse pas tout il faut en tenir
compte je vous remercie merci chers
collègues Madame De Marco
je poursuis le rappel au Règlement sur
la base de la décision du 11 juin 2015
du Conseil constitutionnel sur le fond
les irrespabiliter sont contestables
pour plusieurs raisons une partie de
nous sous en manquements ont été
déclarés irrecevables car il
contredirait l'article 7 c'est très
contestable nos sous amendements du
contredisaient pas l'amendement mais il
se contente dans limiter la portée nous
contestons une interprétation très
extensive du mot contredire enfin même
si cela ne relève pas proprement parler
du règlement une seconde partie d'une
sous-amendement qui visait à exempter
certains métiers du report de l'âge
légal ont été déclarés irrecevables car
il méconnerait le principe d'égalité
devant la loi mais là aussi c'est
parfaitement contestable nous
connaissons la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel qui autorise de
jurisprudence constante que le
législateur règle de façon différente
des situations différentes ou qui
dérochent au principe d'égalité pour des
raisons d'intérêt général le principe
d'égalité n'est en aucun cas un principe
absolu et vous pouvez affirme vous ne
pouvez affirmer avec certitude que ces
amendements étaient incanties
inconstitutionnel seul le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait pu le faire
nous nous demandons également pourquoi
il n'a pas été invoqué que ce motif pour
demander d'y recevoir d'habilité de nos
amendements dans les dispositifs sens
similaires monsieur le Président quand
on se livre un coup de force
réglementaire comme cela était opéré
hier il est préférable d'être d'une
incontestable rigueur
pour reprendre sereinement l'examen de
ce projet de loi le Sénat sonorerait à
annuler toutes les opérations de vote
qui ont eu lieu après la reprise de 1h45
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur à souligne
le président rappellerai règlement aussi
ce référent à la
délibération du 11 juin 2015 du Conseil
constitutionnel alors
ce que l'on a vu cette nuit n'est pas
anodin et restera comme un moment
historique pour cette assemblée
pour tous ceux qui sont là depuis un
certain temps ils n'ont jamais vu ça et
il le disent il y a eu des moments de
tension des moments de combat des
moments de rappel à des règlements de
batailles de procédures ça c'est la vie
des assemblées par contre l'arbitraire
qui tombe d'un coup avec cette violence
au milieu de la nuit qui vient supprimer
des milliers d'amendements et ensuite
des milliers de sous amendements en
moins de trois quarts d'heure c'est à
dire avec l'impossibilité matérielle et
je demanderai des vérifications si
est-ce que matériellement c'est possible
et s'il faut une enquête on peut la
faire
de vérifier que les 2000 amendements
n'étaient pas recevables
alors vous avez fait tout ça mais
attention ce n'est peut-être pas un
service que vous rendez au gouvernement
parce que ce qui a frappé l'opinion
récamobilisée aussi beaucoup c'est que à
l'Assemblée nationale cet article
central qui est la loi c'est toute la
loi tout le reste n'existe pas s'il n'y
a pas cette mesure qui fait un impôt sur
la vie de deux ans sur la vie des
Français
il y a pas eu une discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
attendait qu'elle ait lieu là
et c'est sur cet article pas sur les
autres il y a eu près de 50 heures de
discussion ici tranquille sur tous les
autres
et c'est sur celui-là ou la France
attendait un débat que le couperait est
tombé et bien le Conseil constitutionnel
pourra apprécier la sincérité des débats
et des libération si aucune des deux
assemblées n'a pu discuter sérieusement
sur le fond de l'article 7 la parole est
à Madame à la présidente rossignol
merci monsieur le Président on
rappellera règlement est aussi fondé sur
un t44 bis le Conseil constitutionnel a
deux exigences à l'égard de nos travaux
la clarté et la sincérité je vais
examiner ce qui s'est passé hier à
l'aune de ces deux conditions en ce qui
concerne la sincérité de l'amendement
déposé par Monsieur Savary hier soir
nous avons longuement discuté en
commission monsieur Savary a longuement
développé l'article 7 le soutien qui lui
apportait jamais jamais il n'a été
question d'un amendement du rapporteur
réécrivant une partie de cet article 7
cet amendement est sorti hier soir à
2h30 du matin uniquement uniquement pour
priver le Sénat du débat qu'il attendait
sur l'article 7 donc je commence par
dire que c'est un sincère
c'est une manœuvre en ce qui concerne la
clarté nous avons voté l'os nous avons
voté le Sénat a voté des sénateurs ont
voté hier soir cette nuit dans la plus
grande confusion
c'est un amendement entre deux
suspensions de séance au moment où nous
cherchions encore qu'elles étaient les
conséquences de l'adoption éventuelle de
cet amendement par le Sénat sur les
amendements que nous avions déposés
précédemment au moment où on nous
informait que nous sous amendements que
nous étions en train de déposer était
contraire à l'amendement déposé par
Monsieur Savary contraire changer une
date c'est contraire depuis quand depuis
quand changer une date dans un
amendement est contraire c'était l'objet
de certains de notre sous amendements
donc hier soir vous avez voté un
amendement dans des conditions qui ne
respectent ni l'exigence de sincérité ni
l'exigence de clarté que le Conseil
constitutionnel nous demande
merci chers collègues monsieur
[Applaudissements]
le président mon rappelle au règlement
se fonde sur l'article 44 bis alinéa 4
il est dit dans cet article que les sous
amendements
sont recevables à condition
de n'avoir pas pour effet de contredire
l'amendement
auquel il se rapporte
or parmi les sous amendements qui ont
été déposés il en est un grand nombre
qui ne contredisent pas l'amendement
auquel il se rapporte il est
parfaitement légitime de déposer des
sous amendements qui limitent l'effet de
l'amendement qui réduisent la portée de
l'amendement qui réduisent les
conséquences de l'amendement qui
complètent ce que dit l'amendement tout
cela est légitime ce n'est pas une
contradiction donc monsieur le Président
j'ai l'honneur de vous demander
que qu'il soit procédé à un examen de
l'ensemble des sous amendements
que l'on puisse voir
sous amendement par sous amendement
s'il y a contradiction car la Commission
a été en un quart d'heure dans
l'impossibilité de le faire de telle
manière que tous les sous amendements
qui ne sont pas contradictoires à
l'amendement viennent en science public
sinon c'est un véritable déni par
rapport au droit fondamental à
l'amendement et au sous-amendement qui
est le d'autres merci Jacques collègue
la parole est au président canner
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre à mon tour sur la base de
l'ortie 44 bis et l'ensemble de ces
alinéas ce qui s'est passé hier soir et
particulièrement
il est dit au sein du Sénat je ne
reviendrai pas sur les arguments qui ont
été développés par mes collègues il y a
un instant simplement il y a un contexte
et je contexte est aggravé ce matin par
la Conférence des Présidents article 38
ne relève pas de l'autorité de la
Conférence des Présidents le décision de
d'utiliser les amendements prioritaires
rectificatif non plus par contre
l'article 42 peut-être déclenché sur la
base d'une décision de la Conférence des
Présidents nous sommes opposés parce
qu'il concerne les bancs de cette
immistic mais la décision a été prise ce
qui veut dire monsieur le Président que
ce droit amendement est sous amendement
aujourd'hui pour ce qui reste de notre
débat va être encadré comme jamais au
Sénat par votre décision et par votre
capacité à vouloir plier je le dis les
arguments de notre opposition ici
représentée je le regrette c'est une
image mauvaise qui a été donnée hier
soir tous les arguments développés par
Madame Rossignol feront projet
naturellement d'une réflexion vis-à-vis
d'un éventuel recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel je ne sais pas si je
peux vous dire de vous ressaisir en tout
cas ce que je sais oui de vous ressaisir
vous pour que le débat puisse aller
jusqu'au bout dans les meilleurs
conditions tous ces rappels au règlement
n'ont qu'un objet actif mes chers
collègues tous ces règlements dans un
seul objectif faire que le Sénat puisse
travailler dans de bonnes conditions un
texte aussi important pour nos
concitoyens c'est la volonté qui est la
nôtre je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
partagée par vous toutes merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame de La
Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président tous ceux
qui ont participé nous étions nombreux à
la séance de nuit ont pu constater
l'extrême désordre dans lequel le Sénat
a tenté de travailler et tout cela sera
examiné de près évidemment par le
Conseil constitutionnel notre collègue
Laurence Rossignol a rappelé comment le
Conseil a dans ses jurisprudences
successives instaurer désormais la
nécessité du respect de la sincérité et
de la clarté du débat parlementaire nous
aurons sûrement l'occasion de revenir
sur ce principe
ultérieurement lors de nos débats je le
sens mais je voudrais revenir sur la
façon dont les sous-amendements ont été
traités plusieurs collègues ont fait
mais je voudrais compléter ces
commentaires lorsque madame la
Présidente de roche a donc fait
connaître l'irreciabilité décrétée on
peut dire les choses comme ça sur des
sous amendements qu'il n'avaient jamais
été même lus par la commission il s'est
passé un phénomène encore plus
caricatural à 3 heures du matin le
groupe
communiste a déposé de nouveaux sous
amendements en nombre et
la présidente de la commission dit les
choses suivantes telles que repris dans
le compte rendu analytique je cite
d'autres sous amendements viennent
d'être déposés dans la même veine ils
sont pareillement contradiction avec
l'amendement du rapporteur les mêmes
causes produisant les mêmes effets la
Commission les déclare donc irrecevables
donc nous avons vu une présidente de
commission à son banc avec des commisses
avec des amendements qu'elle n'avait
même pas vu ni lu décrété que par
principe ils étaient irrecevables en
contradiction totale avec le règlement
et la recevabilité des 10 sous
amendements nous demandons donc que
l'ensemble de ces sous amendements soit
premièrement examiner formellement par
la commission deuxièmement que leur
ircevabilité soit explicite et que
infini il soit réellement examiné par le
Sénat
merci chers collègues
nous prenons acte de tous ces rappels au
règlement
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois François Noël buffet
malgré tout il faudrait redire ce qui
s'est passé hier soir hier soir leur
rapporteur a déposé un amendement
réécrivant totalement les dispositions
une partie de l'article 7 c'est sur la
base de cette réécriture que nos
collègues de l'opposition ont déposé
3000 amendements ils ont admis
soudamondement pardon qui se sont leurs
anciens amendements qui se sont traduits
en sous-amendement en réalité ils ont
donc changé de nature
et c'est ce changement de nature qui
fait que l'application habituelle la
règle fait que dès lors qu'ils sont
contraires à l'article la rédaction qui
avait été faite par la mort de Monsieur
Savary était établi il ne peut ils ont
été déclarés irrecevables c'est le
principe qui est admis par tout le monde
depuis longtemps et c'est la règle
normale et habituelle je voudrais redire
si j'ai encore quelques minutes c'est
que nos collègues de l'opposition ont
clairement indiqué il a été constaté je
ne crois par la commission la présente
me semble-t-il la dire ne pas dire de
bêtises que la rédaction était
absolument de ces sous amendements était
absolument
identique à celle des amendements qui
avaient été déposés et que par
conséquent l'analyse pouvait être plus
rapide deuxième point deuxième point et
j'en aurai terminé puisque le président
Kader fait référence à la Conférence des
Présidents de ce matin je voudrais dire
clairement ce qui a été dit puisque j'y
participais il a été dit que la volonté
du groupe d'opposition était de ne pas
voter le texte et d'utiliser tous les
moyens en
sa possession pour pouvoir se poser au
vote du texte mais mais
il a été dit également par les
représentants de l'opposition que la
majorité pouvait aussi utiliser les
moyens qui étaient à sa disposition au
sein du règlement pour voter le texte
donc voilà la réalité du débat
d'aujourd'hui
alors monsieur Durand a demandé la
parole et Madame Linde et puis ensuite
il y aura une réponse de Madame de roche
et puis ensuite on passera l'examen des
amendements
merci monsieur le Président rappelle le
règlement que nous n'allions pas au bout
de l'examen du texte ça pourrait presque
favoriser certains membres de la
majorité sanatoriale qui sont bien
embarrassées par cette situation
deuxième point que je voulais aborder
c'est cette formule qu'a eu la
présidente de roche hier c'est à la page
69 du compte rendu analytique
elle dit la même motion s'appliquerait
au nouveau sous amendement reçu trois
petits points Pierre Laurent dit alors
on est à la lumière elle est restée
allumée Madame Catherine de roche
reprend y compris ceux que la Commission
n'a pas eu le temps d'examiner en effet
ils sont donc ils sont dans la même
veine que les précédents alors qu'on
oppose les recevabilité à des
amendements qu'on a lu pourquoi pas mais
qu'on insère de l'état d'esprit de nos
groupes le contenu d'amendement me
paraît extrêmement grave
chers collègues madame lianman
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur buffet nous explique qu'une
partie des amendements devenus sous
amendements changer de nature parce que
il y avait nécessité de cohérence si je
puis dire avec le contenu de
l'amendement
n'est vrai que pour une partie du
raisonnement développé par Madame de
roche car l'autre il y a un paquet
qu'elle a motivé avec ses motifs on le
conteste mais celui-là à la limite on
peut en discuter en revanche l'autre
partie elle est ils ont été
retoqués j'allais dire juger et
recevable au motif de l'égalité du
non-respect de l'égalité républicaine
mais ça ça motive de contenu
constitutionnel qui ne change pas de
nature quand on a un amendement ou un
sous amendement
soit l'amendement respecte l'égalité
républicaine potentiellement et quand il
devient sous amendement il change pas de
nature au regard de ce critère
RSI proprement donc
[Applaudissements]
Madame la présence de roche
merci monsieur le président
donc
on va revenir si vous me laissez parler
ce serait mieux c'est pas votre habitude
ça j'ai remarqué mais en fin de temps en
temps forcez-vous un peu voilà
[Applaudissements]
présentant la motion qui tendait à
opposer l'exception des recevabilité
je voudrais revenir brièvement en effet
sur les questions qui ont été soulevées
au cours du débat d'hier sur la
régularité la procédure tout d'abord
comment l'exception d'y recevabilité
bien prévu par notre règlement et
jusqu'à sa récente réforme les
commissions avaient notamment recours
pour proposer aussi de déclarer et
recevable des amendements qui créent une
habilitation du gouvernement à légiférer
par ordonnance ou allergir le champ
d'une ordonnance d'une façon générale
l'exception d'y recevabilité permet au
Sénat de ne pas examiner des amendements
ou des sous amendements contraire à la
Constitution je l'ai dit clairement hier
et là c'est le pourquoi les amendements
que l'amendement de la commission a fait
tomber hier soir était des amendements
d'obstruction catalogue des professions
suppression d'alinéa en rafale après
l'examen des 77
dans ce calme on se calme on a encore la
soirée donc ne commencez pas vous
énerver
ils sont et on peut les retrouver dans
les différentes réformes de retraite
leur seul objet est dilatoire les
amendements portant sur le fond du texte
ont été préservés c'était l'objet de
l'amendement du rapporteur ça varie
c'était de faire tomber en effet tous
ces amendements dilatoires et de pouvoir
se consacrer et de pouvoir se consacrer
au fond du texte et un vrai débat qui
intéresse nos concitoyens
les sous amendements déposés en masse
quelques minutes après le dépôt de
l'amendement du rapporteur était les
mêmes si parce que je suis passé du
temps ce qui est en commission bien vu
que je n'étais pas au début de la
commission j'étais dans la salle où en
examinait tous les amendements
d'ailleurs au départ vous avez présenté
non pas des sous amendements mais c'est
intitulés amendement vous savez très
bien que non non madame on peut les
ressortir on peut les ressortir
vous finissez et pas eu des
sous-amendements qui ont été déposés en
effet certains groupes ne se sont au
demeurant même pas la peine de les
modifier c'est ce que je vous dis par
leur nombre et leur objet ils
poursuivaient le même objectif que les
amendements empêcher le déroulement de
la discussion a gagné du temps ces
amendements de production ont été
déposés conformément aux règlements mais
l'exception d'y recevabilité l'est aussi
nous assumons nous aussi de répondre à
l'obstruction permise par le règlement
par les moyens permis par le règlement
la clarté des débats il y a une
certainement lorsque nous sortons de ces
longs tunnel de discussion qui n'ont
d'autres objets que de refaire à l'envie
la discussion générale et nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est passer à l'examen
des articles sur le fond le camp
certains orateurs
vraiment monsieur Assouline si vous
pouvez aujourd'hui je vous l'ai dit hier
arrêtez de hurler en permanence
si mais si vous rendez même pas compte
on dit toujours que lorsqu'on hurle
c'est qu'on n'a pas beaucoup d'arguments
certains orateurs se sont étonnés que
l'exception d'y recevabilité arrive
après l'examen en commission et soit
opposé à des sous amendements
identiques à des amendements examinés
par la connaît la commission
reconnaissant ainsi qu'il s'agit c'est
bien des mêmes vous l'avez dit et pas
des heures à la Commission pour les
examiner je voudrais tout d'abord
rappeler qu'un amendement recevable ne
fait pas forcément ça a été dit sous
amendement recevable un amendement
unifie le texte un sous amendement
magnifiquement dont il ne doit pas
contredire le sens et c'est ce que vous
contestez mais on pourrait je voudrais
ensuite indiquer que l'exception d'y
recevabilité s'oppose en séance et que
ce n'est pas parce qu'un amendement est
examiné en commission qu'elle ne peut
pas par la suite lui être opposé en
séance c'est ce que nous avons fait et
je peux vous dire que pour être allé
dans la salle où les amendements étaient
examinés il y avait un nombre très
important d'administrateur et aucun
amendement n'est passé dans les mailles
du filet merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je partage je partage une
partie de vos propos il y a eu 48 heures
48 heures de discussion depuis quelques
jours avant d'arriver à cet article 7
il y a eu
deux deux articles déterminants pour
cette réforme des retraites à savoir
l'article 1 qui ferme les régimeux
spéciaux
nous étions favorables de ce côté là
vous étiez défavorable le première
partie et puis après vous avez proposé
des dates de fermeture un peu plus
tardives mais vous avez proposé la
fermeture des services des régimes
spéciaux comme quoi parfois on peut se
retrouver et puis il y a eu sur
l'article 2
la discussion importante le débat sur
l'emploi des seniors avec des
propositions venant du gouvernement pour
certaines l'index des seniors venant de
ces bancs là pour d'autres le CDI senior
et vous vous êtes opposés vous vous êtes
opposés à cela et c'est votre droit ces
débats ont duré 4 heures sur 48 heures
sur 48 heures de discussion 4 heures de
débat car effectivement le reste était
un monologue où vous présentiez votre
vision très apocalyptique du monde du
travail avec votre volonté de vous
opposer sans présenter vos amendements
car si nous avions entendu la
présentation de ces amendements je pense
que ceux qui nous écoutent auraient
changé d'avis
et puis ensuite vous dire
vous dire que effectivement vous avez eu
un effet de surprise mais la vivacité de
lecture de madame la Présidente pour
juger de la recevabilité
de leur homme sevabilité de ces
amendements et identique à votre
vivacité pour proposer dans la minute
3000 sous amendements
quel effet de surprise
ni avaient-ils pas quelque part une
préparation
on pourrait penser contenu de ce qui se
passe qu'au départ que nous ayons des
discussions que l'on vous soupçonne de
vouloir vous entraver au bon déroulé des
débats mais quand on ressort 3000
amendements c'est qu'on veut s'opposer
au débat et en conséquence
dites-le clairement dites-le nous ne
voulons pas voter cette réforme nous ne
voulons pas débattre sur un sujet
sociétal et arrivé au vote mais dites-le
n'hésitez pas
on avait clos les rappelles au règlement
il y a eu des réponses qui ont été
apportées nous allons maintenant passer
dans la discussion des articles
écoutez je pense qu'on a laissé 99
monsieur le Président vous êtes
intervenus déjà sur le rappel au
règlement il n'y a pas une deuxième
intervention
ce n'est pas un rappeur j'entends la
demande de suspension mais c'est à mon
appréciation bien sûr la prestation du
président de séance de savoir s'il faut
suspendre ou pas la séance mais donc
je vais la suspendre 5 minutes monsieur
le Président la séance 5 minutes
monsieur le Président je vous demande
voilà
et nous votant fort dans ces débats au
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites avec
une nouvelle suspension de séance après
les débats très tendus de la nuit
dernière les sénateurs de gauche qui ont
multiplié les rappels au règlement pour
dénoncer les outils réglementaires qui
ont été utilisés par la droite
sénatoriale la nuit dernière et aussi le
fait que la commission des affaires
sociales a déclaré et recevable des
milliers d'amendements de la gauche
après un examen très rapide de ces
amendements des sous amendements
précisément pour en parler on va
retrouver Quentin calmé qui a suivi la
reprise de ces débats cet après-midi
Quentin on peut le dire que à la gauche
c'est reparti sur les chapeaux de roue
oui exactement Alex et on repart
exactement là où on s'est interrompu
hier à 3h30 si vous étiez avec nous en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
peut-être pas alors on va réexpliquer ce
qui s'est joué hier la droite a tenté de
couper court à la discussion autour de
1100 amendements déposés par la gauche
et qui venait ralentir le débat autour
de l'article 7 l'ancien tel prix et bien
René Paul Savary le rapporteur de la
branche vieillesse qui vient de
s'exprimer à déposer un amendement à
l'article 7 un amendement qui venait
redéfinir l'article 7 avec des termes
assez proches de ce qu'il y avait à
l'origine dans le texte sauf que cette
manœuvre de la part de la Commission de
la droite et du centre a eu pour effet
de faire tomber 1100 amendements qui
étaient donc en cours de discussion café
la gauche à ce moment-là hier elle a
tenté de déposer des centaines de sous
amendements et ce sont ces sous
amendements là qui ont été jugés
irrecevables en une demi-heure de en une
demi-heure de réunion de la commission
de l'affaire sociale cette décision là
est critiquée depuis maintenant la
reprise de 16h30 par des dizaines de
rappels réglement de la gauche et on a
entendu les justifications de la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales également du rapporteur qui ont
essayé d'expliquer pourquoi il y avait
eu ce rejet massif de sous-amendement et
la gauche qui de son côté donc il y a un
détournement du Règlement du Sénat et on
entend du toutes ces prises de parole
aussi de la gauche qui dit que ça va
fragiliser le texte
constitutionnellement car il y a
maintenant des doutes sur la sincérité
des débats et qui donc rejette le fait
que leur amendements n'étaient pas et
bien admissible au débat Alex merci
beaucoup Quentin et pendant cette
suspension de séance pour en parler
j'accueille sur ce plateau Olivier
Pacaud bonjour vous êtes sénateur
rattaché au groupe les républicains ici
au Sénat un mot sur ces multiples
rappels au règlement de la gauche qui
dénonce les pratiques de la droite
sénatoriale sur la procédure de débat
sur cette réforme des retraites les
ceintures de gauche estiment que leurs
collègues de droite porte un coup très
fort au droit d'amendement qui a un
droit d'amendement constitutionnel des
parlementaires comment vous réagissez
écoutez si
la constitutionnalité des débats a été
entre guillemets mis à mal
je crois que nos collègues socialistes
saisiront éventuellement qui de droit a
priori ce n'est pas le cas en fait ils
sont dans la lignée de leur attitude
depuis le début de l'ouverture des
débats c'est-à-dire qu'il multiplie les
prises de parole c'est une forme un peu
plus polie d'obstruction ni plus ni
moins aujourd'hui ce que nous attendons
ce que nous espérons c'est de pouvoir
continuer à débattre du fameux article 7
et notamment il reste beaucoup
d'amendements quand même il y en a un
millier qui ont effectivement qui sont
tombés entre guillemets il en reste
beaucoup sur des sujets très variés
comme 75 il en reste 75 c'est pas neutre
moi j'en défendrai un personnellement
pour rétablir l'égalité de traitement
entre les professeurs des écoles et les
enseignants du secondaire pour l'âge de
départ à la retraite tout ça il faut
l'aborder et si on continue
effectivement dans l'obstruction ce qui
est le cas là depuis un peu plus d'une
demi-heure voire trois quarts d'heure on
avancera pas et donc en face la droite
sénatoriale doit continuer à utiliser
ces outils réglementaires pour accélérer
accélérer les débats
écoutez on est là pour travailler on est
là pour voter un texte donc ce sont des
outils réglementaires qui appartiennent
effectivement au règlement intérieur
mais il s'agit pas de la part pas des
républicains puisque c'est quand même
une décision qui avait été prise par le
président de séance de biaiser le débat
mais de au contraire le fluidifier merci
beaucoup Olivet Paco je vous laisse
regagner c'est à l'hémicycle du Sénat
puisque la séance a repris sur cette
réforme des retraites et puis se balayer
l'ensemble des sous amendements qui ont
été déclarés irrecevables
je pense que si j'avais pu vous demander
cela
vous avez donc merci pour la suspension
préalable merci donc la suspension n'a
pas permis la commission de regarder
mais enfin ça a été regardé par la
présidente elle l'a dit tout à l'heure
donc on va on va commencer comme le
souhaitait la plupart d'entre vous
discuter sur le fond sur l'article 7 et
donc on a un certain nombre
d'amendements en discussion commune dont
un certain nombre ont été retirés dont
un certain nombre ont été retirés donc
l'amendement 165 230 ont été retirés
nous avons le 1142 de Monsieur
Ménonville
est-ce qu'il est là Monsieur mélenville
non il a retiré le 2496 madame Boyer a
été retiré donc nous passons au 263
madame Lubin qui le défend
qui ne défend cet amendement
madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
proposé un amendement avec mon groupe
qui tend au lieu de donner une surcote
de 5% aux femmes qui arrivent avec tous
leurs trimestres à l'âge de 63 ans
donc leur permettre d'avoir 5 % de plus
quand elles prennent leur retraite à 64
ans ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait juste à nos yeux dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui une femme qui
arrive à 62 ans avec tous ces trimestres
et qui décident volontairement de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans peut avoir 10%
de surcote donc là avec cette
proposition au final elle perd 5% de
surcote donc nous ce que nous proposons
ça serait bien si elle pouvait avoir un
peu de silence à côté s'il vous plaît
merci et donc non mais c'est difficile
c'est
[Musique]
il est retiré donc on a pu en fait qu'un
un seul amendement puisque le 2189 a été
retiré le 168 aussi le 1972 aussi le
2190 aussi donc sur cet amendement
2633 la commission la vie de la
Commission
oui merci effectivement c'est
intéressant de penser à cette carrière
des mères de famille qui se traduit
derrière par des pensions qui sont pas
toujours à la hauteur et les majorations
de
les majorations au d'assurance qui sont
accordées pour les maires de famille
sont effectivement tout à fait
intéressantes à la fois pour combler la
carrière et aider à arriver au taux
plein mais également pour avoir une
reconnaissance par rapport à cette
volonté de concilier une carrière et une
maternité elles sont cependant
différentes entre le régime public et
privé puisque c'est quatre trimestres
pour la maternité plus 4 trimestres à
distribuer pour l'éducation des enfants
d'un côté et seulement deux trimestres
dans le régime public donc c'est
apprendre en compte la différence madame
Lubin entre un âge avancé de départ d'un
an et une surcote c'est-à-dire qu'on
continue à travailler comparé à 64 ans
et à ce moment là ce que nous proposons
c'est de prendre en compte cette effort
supplémentaire et de le récompenser
l'avantage c'est que on va dans la
philosophie de la réforme que
voulez-vous c'est quand même les
Français l'ont bien compris travailler
plus et un deuxième avantage par hassas
c'est que ça augmente la pension de ces
femmes ça réduit les cas entre les
niveaux de pension entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons choisi ce dispositif et qui
argument supplémentaire me semble-t-il
permet de pas être discriminatoire par
rapport à la Cour européenne si vous
faites un âge avancé pour les femmes
réservées aux femmes il y a une
différence de traitement par rapport aux
hommes c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre amendement je vous invite à le
soutenir et vraiment la meilleure
solution par rapport à ces difficultés
que peuvent rencontrer les maires de
famille donc c'est un invité
favorablement monsieur le ministre
merci Michel président de madame la
Présidente de la Commission Madame et
Monsieur laporteur la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable pour
plusieurs raisons la première concerne
cette question d'égalité que monsieur le
rapporteur vient d'évoquer je n'y
reviens pas il y a une deuxième raison
qui est relève de la mécanique même de
l'amendement que Madame Libin défendu la
surcote quand on parle de surcote est
accessible aujourd'hui et le sera demain
dans les mêmes conditions à deux
conditions cumulatives la première est
d'atteindre d'avoir atteint l'âge
d'ouverture des droits tels que fixés au
régime général et la deuxième est
d'avoir atteint la durée d'affiliation
au régime requise pour pouvoir faire
valoir ses droits à taux plein et c'est
vraiment ces deux conditions qu'il y a
une possibilité de surcote et donc une
surcote qui intervient après la od et à
condition d'avoir l'intégralité des
trimestres requis pour demander et
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
il y a une difficulté dans l'amendement
que vous présentez madame la sénatrice
qui consiste à imaginer créer des âges
différenciés finalement non pas entre
les femmes et les hommes mais tel que
vous le présentez entre les mères et les
hommes puisqu'il faudrait bénéficier de
trimestre au titre de la maternité je le
dis de manière un peu rapide pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'un âge avancé notre
préférence va un amendement adopter par
la commission des affaires sociales dont
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de parler qui a
été initié par le président Retailleau
parce qu'il permet de cumuler les
avantages de deux systèmes premier
avantage et qu'il permet pour des femmes
qui ont une carie Rachid nous savons que
les femmes sont plus exposées que les
hommes en cariaché de pouvoir continuer
à mettre en oeuvre et utiliser les
trimestres validé au titre de la
maternité pour compléter leur durée
d'affiliation requise et ainsi pouvoir
partir à l'âge d'ouverture des droits
dans 900 les conditions de fixation de
celui-ci à ton plan et sans décote c'est
un élément de protection parce que ça
permet justement d'éviter la décote pour
des femmes en cariacées qui tentait que
le nombre de trimestres ainsi validé est
suffisant la deuxième utilisation qui
permet cet amendement adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales et de
dire que si un assuré
plus généralement une assurée mais c'est
générique a atteint à la fois l'âge de
63 ans et dans le même temps la durée
d'affiliation requise 168 trimestre
aujourd'hui 172 demain en 2027 il y a
non pas la possibilité mais
automatiquement une surcote pour les
trimestres cotisés entre les 63 ans si
tenté que la Dar était éteinte et les 64
ans ce qui à l'échelle d'une année
représente une majoration non pas des
trimestres acquis mais de la totalité de
la pension de 5% hauteur de 1,25% par
trimestre et donc la préférence du
gouvernement il s'ajustifiera la vie
favorable ultérieurement à l'amendement
adopté par la commission tient au fait
que par cet amendement nous gardons le
bénéfice d'une majoration de durée pour
les assurer principalement les femmes
ayant une carrière hachée ou incomplète
à la fin et que nous pouvons prévoir une
possibilité de sur code pour celles qui
ont une carrière complète et ça répond à
une évolution de société évolution de
société qui fait que le taux d'emploi
des femmes a progressé c'est heureux et
qui fait que la conciliation de la vie
professionnelle avec la maternité et
sinon plus facile en tout cas moins
difficile qu'elle ne l'était il y a 20
30 ou 40 ans et donc c'est cet intérêt
là qu'on trouvons à l'amendement alors
que celui que vous proposait propose des
âges différenciés qui ne nous paraissent
pas très acceptable endroit en tout cas
on regarde du principe d'égalité et
peut-être me connaître ce double aspect
bon pour toutes ces raisons la vie est
favorable et c'est la justifiera
monsieur le Président un avis
défavorable sur les autres amendements à
l'exception de celui de la commission
des affaires sociales ils ont été
retirés les autres amendements monsieur
le ministre donc j'ai des demandes
d'explication de vote madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
sommes aujourd'hui 8 mars journée
internationale de lutte pour le droit
des femmes c'est quand même ça tombe
très bien c'est amendement et on le sait
on le dit et c'est répété ce sont les
femmes qui vont être les grandes
perdantes de ce projet de réforme de
départ et de recul de l'âge de des pâtes
de départ à la retraite que cet
amendement et bien je le voterai puisque
en termes de financement c'est un texte
de financement là il y a pas de surcoût
et pas plus coûteux qu'une surcote de 5%
qui est prévue par l'amendement déposé
par René Paul Savary et sur le fond
encore une fois par rapport à ce projet
de loi injuste et injuste surtout envers
les femmes je voterai l'amendement de
présenté par mon groupe et Monique Lubin
en premier et puis je pose une question
qui m'étonne qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
débat où tous les amendements se
retirent avant d'être discuté où est
l'esprit du débat du Sénat où elle a
démocratie
merci monsieur le Président alors
puisque on parle du principe d'égalité
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est l'égalité
quand à 43 ans on a les conditions d'un
taux plein l'égalité entre les mers et
les femmes voilà et même voilà donc là
on Déroche à l'égalité cette dérogation
que vous comptez tout à l'heure
une autre égalité ça serait de dire 5%
pour tous ceux qui ont atteint homme ou
femme et dans les femmes mères ou femmes
sans enfant le taux plein à 63 ans mais
je voudrais surtout insister ce que vous
dites monsieur le rapporteur à savoir
que grâce au fait que vous les obligez à
travailler un an plus elles vont avoir
une meilleure pension mais c'est
méconnettes le mécanisme de la surcotte
quand on dit une surcote de 5%
c'est actuarielle vous devez le savoir
ça veut dire que le patrimoine retraite
c'est-à-dire tout ce qu'elles auront en
termes de retraite de pension de
retraite est strictement égale et neutre
par rapport à l'augmentation de 5%
donnée par la surcotte c'est un principe
actuarial neutre ça veut dire que vous
oubliez un petit détail vous dites elles
ont une pension supérieure vous oubliez
qu'elle travaille un an plus et pendant
qu'elle travaille un an plus elle ne
touche pas de pension et le patrimoine
retraite on y reviendra qui est la somme
des pensions dans toute la durée de
retraite est strictement égal dans un
cas comme dans un autre donc vous et les
femmes je serai tenté de dire si à 63
ans avant elle travaillait elle avait
une surcote elle gagne moins avec cette
réforme forcément puisque
comme l'a dit ma collègue pouvait la
voir des 62 ans donc voilà ne dites pas
que vous augmentez les pensions parce
que
certes vous les augmentez c'est un
travail jusqu'à 70 ans aussi elle
augmentera sa pension mais elle perdra
en patrimoine retraite merci chers
collègues la parole est au président
Retailleau
rappel au règlement je demande
l'application d'article 38
merci monsieur le président
donc on a été saisi par Monsieur le
Président du Groupe républicain d'une
demande de clôture des explications de
vote sur l'amendement 263
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle qu'on aplication de
l'article 38 à Linéa du règlement
la clôture peut être proposée lorsque au
moins deux heures d'avis contraire sont
intervenus
conformément à la ligne à 3 du même
article
je vais consulter le Sénat alors
attendez d'abord d'abord il faut qu'il y
a deux interventions pardon
il peut y avoir
sur la clôture il peut y avoir une
explication de votre par groupe donc
madame la Présidente rossignol
monsieur le Président retaille vous avez
fait tomber quasiment tous nos
amendements sur l'article 7 vous voulez
vous voulez un débat le plus restreint
possible même vos collègues qui avaient
des amendements c'est la secte jaune des
amendements il se suicide tous
et quand on a un amendement qui porte
sur la question de des bonifications
pour les agents de la fonction publique
ou des majorations de durées d'assurance
pour les femmes du secteur privé même
pas celui-là vous voulez qu'on discute
même pas celui-là un 8 mars mais vous
vous rendez compte ce que vous faites
mais c'est plus c'est plus c'est une
honte
c'est plus c'est plus ce que vous nous
quand tu permets c'est plus
l'application du règlement c'est plus
l'application du règlement c'est une
volonté délibérée de faire taire
l'opposition par tous les moyens y
compris sur les sujets parce que la
personne va le dire nous expliquer qu'on
est hors sujet que ces contradictoires
qu'on peut pas en parler et tout à
l'heure sur les amendements de Monsieur
Savary on aura le droit de s'exprimer ou
faire comment on fait on fait un mot au
président moi je le président
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous dire
si on aura le droit de s'exprimer je
vous remercie beaucoup de votre
attention c'est ça l'idée c'est de nous
humilier en plus mais c'est pas nous que
vous humilier c'est les femmes toutes
les femmes
merci
merci chers collègues monsieur Lemoine
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président sur
l'application cet article 38 on entend
beaucoup de récrimination mais
j'aimerais que nous nous souvenions des
conditions dans lesquelles nous nous
sommes fixés tous ensemble cette règle
quelque part de bien vivre ensemble
voilà et bien oui et bien oui
tout cela est issu d'un rapport qui a
été fait par un membre de la majorité à
l'époque
UMP un membre de l'opposition PS c'était
en mars 2015 le bureau du Sénat a adopté
ce rapport dans ce rapport figurait
cette recommandation cette
recommandation était inscrite dans la
proposition de résolution que le
président de l'archet a déposé c'était
l'article 10 de cette proposition de
résolution et vous pouvez aller voir les
travaux tant commission qu'en séance cet
article 10 qui désormais inscrit
l'article 38 dans notre règlement notre
Constitution commune et bien il n'y a eu
aucun amendement le remettant en cause
ni en commission ni en séance il était
adopté sans modification il n'y a donc
pas eu à l'époque de révolution contre
cet article il y a même eu un
assentiment large et
je dois dire d'ailleurs que ce chantier
sur le règlement il faisait suite à des
premiers réflexions enclenchées par
Jean-Pierre Bel à l'époque et donc tout
cela je crois que nous l'avons assez
largement décidé tous ensemble j'ai
entendu hier dans les débats l'un des
orateurs
sur les bancs de la gauche dire nul ne
peut se prévaloir de sa propre turpitude
je crois que ça s'applique parfaitement
la situation que nous vivons aujourd'hui
merci chers collègues madame Cohen pour
le groupe CRCE
monsieur le Président Retailleau vous
sortez l'article 38 pour nous empêcher
de parler alors on va dire du côté des
bancs LR bah oui mais finalement on est
déjà mercredi donc nous avons
suffisamment des battu c'est un état la
conception que nous avons du débat en
plus on a dit que l'article 7 c'était
vraiment le cœur de la réforme et en
plus vous attaquez un amendement le 8
mars qui concerne mais oui mes chers
collègues ça ne vous plaît pas mais
c'est la journée de lutte pour les
droits des femmes vous attaquez un
amendement qui peut effectivement
permettre un débat sur quelle est notre
conception de l'égalité professionnelle
quel est notre conception de l'égalité
au niveau des retraites quelle est notre
conception de la progression des
salaires et des carrières féminines vous
n'en voulez pas et en plus moi j'entends
une petite musique quand même que j'ai
dénoncé au nom de mon groupe quand il a
quand nous avons présenté la motion
référendaire j'entends une petite
musique au niveau des bancs LR soutenu
par les bancs du gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous voulez favoriser vous voulez
pas favoriser les femmes vous voulez
favoriser les maires de famille c'est un
choix qui est vraiment problématique
nous nous voulons l'égalité absolue pour
toutes les femmes et en plus vous n'avez
pas dû lire non plus cet amendement là
de ma collègue parce que il porte sur
les droits familiaux ça devrait vous
intéresser monsieur Retailleau vous qui
prenez la famille comme étant le net
plus ultra papa Maman Les enfants il
faut un petit peu réfléchir
merci chers collègues
alors madame consémont pour le groupe
madame ponce pour le groupe c'est
[Musique]
si vous voulez
merci monsieur le Président moi j'invite
les Français à réécouter les trois
interventions qui vous qui ont précédé
et qui ont vous ont fait dire qu'il faut
que le débat s'arrête ces trois
interventions regardez messieurs les
Français le font on était au fond quand
je parlais quand même de patrimoine
retraite et de calcul actuariale j'étais
au fond bon donc j'en déduis que vous ne
voulez pas effectivement qu'on débattre
de l'article 7 et je vous rappelle quand
même que vous avez osé à l'Assemblée
nationale vous vous réclamez des
syndicats pour dire que c'était quand
même très triste de ne pas avoir débattu
de l'article 7 nous y sommes nous avons
jusqu'à dimanche il y avait peut-être
deux jours sur l'article 7 et vous le et
vous ne voulez pas les avoir ce que vous
voulez c'est qu'on discute pas de
l'article 7 parce que c'est dans
l'article 7 qui a les conséquences sur
les travailleurs inég brutal de cette
loi c'est dans l'article 7 que vous
allez créer vous allez prendre 18
milliards sur les travailleurs ce que
vous voulez par contre c'est qu'on parle
beaucoup des autres articles vous savez
ceux qui rendent au travailleur et qui
ont été payés par les travailleurs les 3
milliards donc vous voulez pas qu'on
parle de 18 milliards et de leurs
conséquences sur la pénibilité sur le
travail sur les femmes sur les ouvriers
mais vous voulez mettre tout le débat
jusqu'à dimanche sur les trois petits
milliards de mesures d'atténuation de la
brutalité de cette réforme et
effectivement le le gouvernement ne
communique que sur ces 3 milliards donc
nous on discutera des mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de la
réforme mais avant il faut parler de la
brutalité de la réforme c'est l'article
7 et c'est ça que vous voulez pas avoir
pour mieux mettre l'éclairage sur les
mesures d'accompagnement voilà merci
mes chers collègues et il y a encore sur
cet article 7 pas mal d'amendements donc
qui nous permettront quand même
d'aborder je l'espère en tout cas le
fond du sujet et
pour l'instant nous sommes dans
l'application du règlement dans
l'application de l'article 38 du
Règlement qui a été demandé par le
groupe les républicains et qui prévoit
strictement les modalités du débat sur
la proposition de clôture à savoir un
orateur par groupe
donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire est-ce qu'il y a encore des
groupes qui se demandent à s'exprimer
monsieur Canevet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres chers collègues j'ai
l'impression à entendre les propos que
je viens d'entendre justement que
certains confondent le débat et
l'obstruction à quoi a-t-on assisté
depuis à quoi a-t-on assisté depuis
plusieurs jours ce sont des tentatives
d'obstruction ce n'est pas le débat et
le débat devrait avoir lieu si justement
vous étiez respectueux de la capacité de
chacun à pouvoir s'exprimer et le groupe
de l'Union centriste regrette le groupe
de l'Union centrée se regrette justement
que par l'obstruction par la
prolongation des débats par des
amendements qui n'ont aucun sens parce
qu'ils sont similaires il suffit de les
présenter de façon rationnelle et le
débat pour avoir lieu donc on n'a pas
d'autre choix à mon avis que de soutenir
la proposition qui vient d'être faite
pour pouvoir avancer et pouvoir enfin
examiner les vrais sujets à l'ordre du
jour de ce texte
merci chers collègues
donc je vais soumettre aux voix
l'application de cet article 38
conformément à son alinéa 3 cet article
je vais consulter le Sénat à mallevé qui
est pour l'application de l'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
l'article 38 donc s'applique et par
conséquent nous
passons alors au vote sur l'amendement
donc avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté alors ensuite nous avons une
motion
4766 qui tend à opposé d'exception dire
recevabilité c'est monsieur le
rapporteur
oui bien sûr collègue motion des
recevabilité sur
[Musique]
deux amendements les
2378 et les 4322 ce sont pour les mêmes
motifs qu'hier que ces amendements qui
concernent des catégories particulières
d'assurer son contraire aux principes
d'égalité consacrés par l'article 6 de
la Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen
c'est le rapporteur alors il y a un
orateur contre la motion d'y
recevabilité
on est dans la motion des recevabilité
monsieur Assouline
vous l'avez pas
la motion est à l'encontre de deux
amendements de 1378 432
monsieur Assouline
oui bien entendu que c'est de la même
veine et
on a donné les explications de cette
nuit on les a continué
sur la réforme des retraites alors pour
vous préciser un petit peu les choses on
le rappelle un dessinateur sont sur
l'article 7 qui reporte l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans et ils discutait d'un
amendement socialiste pour permettre aux
maires de famille de conserver leur
trimestre gagné grâce à la parentalité
même si elle n'avait pas atteint l'âge
légal à 64 ans et à ce moment-là et bien
la droite sénatoriale a dégainé le
fameux article 38 du Règlement du Sénat
alors pour en parler je vais retrouver
quand un calmer en tribune de
l'hémicycle Quentin rappelez-nous un peu
ce que c'est cet article 38 oui elle
vous le disiez Alex en est en train de
discuter sur un amendement socialiste de
Monique cubain il y a eu trois prises de
parole c'est le maximum que l'on a
atteint pour l'instant sur le fond des
articles et là Bruno retaillew a demandé
effectivement l'application de l'article
38 qui vient contraindre le nombre
d'orateurs par amendement puis provoquer
un vote ça permet bien d'empêcher les
socialistes en l'occurrence la gauche
sénatoriale plus généralement de
multiplier les explications de vote les
prises de parole sur un amendement et ça
vient d'être dénoncé encore une fois
comme une forme bien de bâillon de
l'opposition sénatoriale par la gauche
sénatoriale Alex merci Quentin et les
sénateurs sont en train de discuter
d'une motion d'irrecevabilité à la
Commission des averses sociales qui
déclarent de nouveaux amendements
déposés par la gauche il recevables on
écoute David à Soline les choses sont
claires
quand on vient argumenter ici que il y a
des milliers d'amendements un peu trop
similaire pour les retirer là c'est le
seul qui est maintenu et vous mettez
l'article 38 vous empêchez le débat et
vous ne voulez pas discuter de l'article
7 qui n'a pas été débattu à l'Assemblée
nationale merci scandale merci chers
collègues
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cette motion monsieur le ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président au
gouvernement de conteste jamais sur ce
texte comme sur les autres les décisions
de la commission des commissions tant
pour la recevabilité que pour les
recevabilités donc je m'en remets
évidemment au Sénat monsieur Assouline
dit à l'instant qu'un certain nombre
d'amendements pouvaient avoir un
caractère secondaire j'en prends acte et
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises dans les séances précédentes
qu'il est vrai que parmi les nombreux
amendements qui avaient été déposés
ensuite transporté en sous-amendement et
cela aussi sans juger de la recevabilité
ou de lire recevabilité certains nous
surprenaient à la fois par leur carrière
leur caractère redondant ou encore par
exemple ce qu'il prévoyait de maintenir
à 62 plutôt que 64 ans l'âge de départ à
la retraite des internes en médecine si
vous connaissez beaucoup d'interne en
médecine de 62 ou 64 ans cela peut
interroger cela monte juste le caractère
répétitif de l'opération et donc
évidemment je me remets à la vie de la
Commission
merci
Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains sur cette notion
d'irres-savvabilité
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
et les sénateurs qui sont donc en train
de voter sur l'irrecevabilité ou non de
deux amendements qui ont été déposés par
la gauche et que la commission des
affaires sociales considère comme y
recevables notamment au nom de notre
Constitution et de l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes ce sont les
arguments qui ont été avancés par la
Commission des averses sociales et donc
ce que dit la commission elle propose de
ne pas les examiner ils ne sont pas
recevables et maintenant les sénateurs
vont voter sur cette motion d'y
recevabilité alors que il y a quelques
minutes il y avait un débat tendu après
que la droite sénatoriale a utilisé
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat pour
clôturer les débats les prises de parole
de la gauche sur un amendement qui
concernait les maires de famille on
écoute le résultat de ce scrutin public
qui se termine du scrutin public donc on
le rappelle les sénateurs qui votent sur
leur tablette électronique et le vote de
chaque sénateur est donc rendu public
sur cette motion rendue publique sur le
site internet du Sénat on écoute le
résultat
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues aujourd'hui
les exploitants agricoles où les
employés sont déjà plus de 20% à être en
incapacité dès leur première année de
retraite et 34% des ouvriers sont déjà
contraints dans les activités de la vie
quotidienne dès leur entrée à la
retraite c'est la preuve s'il en était
besoin que l'allongement de la durée de
la vie n'est pas un argument pour
justifier le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et cela est encore
moins vrai dans les territoires
ultra marins en effet l'espérance de vie
y est six années inférieures en moyenne
à celle des habitants de la métropole la
réforme doit donc tenir compte des
réalités se présente un moment souhaite
l'âge de 60 que l'âge de 64 ans pour un
départ à la retraite ne soit pas pris en
compte pour les habitants de la
Polynésie française nous ne pouvons pas
ajouter de l'inégalité à l’inégalité
touché à l'âge de départ à la retraite
risque de ne faire que creuser les
écarts les habitants d'outre-mer
méritent mieux que ça avec cet
amendement nous refusons donc
l'application de l'article 7 et de cette
réforme dans sa globalité aux habitants
de Polynésie française merci de votre
attention merci chers collègues et c'est
plusieurs sous amendements le 4768 qui
représente
même les bain
à fixer un délai minimal ah non c'est le
4 4769 pardon
c'est pareil
c'est un amendement qui tend à fixer un
délai minimal à la prise en compte des
critères ou endroit au départ à la
retraite par les fonctionnaires
résidents en Polynésie française prévue
par cette amendement il semble
préférable de prévoir un délai de trois
mois avant la prise en compte d'intérêt
ouvrant ce droit en fait comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure à ma collègue Raymond
deponsemont
l'intérêt sur cet article 7 c'était de
discuter de la brutalité de ce projet de
loi et c'était de discuter de ce que
nous pouvions effectivement proposer ou
amender pour le rendre moins brutal même
si nous nous souhaitons sa suppression
voilà et donc
par les artifices que vous utilisez vous
nous empêchez de discuter de la
brutalité de ce projet de loi et des
conséquences qu'il aura sur des millions
de salariés dans ce pays
merci chers collègues donc le 477
considère qu'il a été défendu il va
l'être il va l'être monsieur le
Président
sur le Président chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
dans le cadre d'un débat dont vous avez
sciemment dégradé la qualité et le
niveau
par les procédures que vous avez
choisies dans le règlement en
particulier je trouve personnellement
très très utile que c'est sous
amendements nous permettent d'évoquer
les différentes catégories
socioprofessionnelles de la population
française qui sont mis à mal par ce
projet de réforme des retraites uniques
et ces particules le cas avec cette
amendement 4767 qui vise à modifier le
critère de prise en compte de départ à
la retraite pour les fonctionnaires qui
résident en Polynésie française et de ne
tenir compte que de leur intérêt
matériel la notion d'intérêt morale qui
apparaît dans le dans le texte étant
pour le moins subjectif
chers collègues de 477
sous amendements
sur le président
c'est le ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais profiter de ce sous amendement
pour attirer l'attention sur les
fonctionnaires d'État qui résident en
Polynésie française fonctionnaire d'État
ce sont des policiers sont les contrôles
les contrôleurs du trafic aérien ce sont
tout le personnel du Haut-Commissariat
vous le savez c'est fonctionnaires qui
sont en Polynésie française touchent une
bonification de salaire du fait de la
différence différentielle du coût de la
vie entre la France entre la métropole
entre la grille indiciaire de la de la
métropole et puis bien évidemment le
coût réel de la vie ce coup cette
différentielle il est de 84 de 0,84%.
c'est à dire que un fonctionnaire d'État
qui se trouve en Polynésie française a
un salaire de
1,84 par rapport à ce qu'il serait en
métropole pour tenir compte justement de
ce coup de la vie le fonctionnaire
français
paye des cotisations sur 1 84 or
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 2008 le
ministre de l'époque qui s'appelait Yves
Jégo a considéré que l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite qui permettait
donc au retraites d'être majorée de 94%
contenu du coût de la vie et bien que
c'était qu'il y avait des dérives on
appelait ça des retraites cocotiers
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
fonctionnaires d'une certaine façon qui
était en France et puis qui sont dit il
y a une bonification d'un 84 si je veux
en outre-mer donc je vais en profiter
donc il a dit et bien tout simplement on
le supprime sur 20 ans on le supprime
sur 20 ans ce qui fait que les
fonctionnaires d'État qui décident de
rester en Polynésie eux vont se trouver
dans une situation où le retraite va
être minorée par rapport au coût de la
vie donc il est important à travers ces
sous amendements de proposer donc des
mesures compensatoires sachant qu'il y a
une négociation qui est en cours avec
les le service du haut-commissaire pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les
fonctionnaires d'État qui souhaitent
rester en Polynésie puisse avoir les
conditions de vie descente et le 477
défendu
4573 477
monsieur le ministre il faut que nous
prenions le temps quand même de pouvoir
intervenir quoi
cet avant de manche cher collègue
concerne la Polynésie française
et donc il est question dans ce texte de
pouvoir permettre une retraite des
fonctionnaires prévus par cet homme
demande il semble préférable de prévoir
un délai de six mois avant la prise en
compte des intérêts ouvrant à ce droit
merci
le 477
merci merci monsieur le Président donc
dans la suite donc tous ces amendements
portent sur la même thématique vous
l'avez compris mais sont importants
Jean-Michel Houlgate a très bien
expliqué quelle était la problématique
et ce délai effectivement de départ à la
retraite pour les fonctionnaires de
l'État résidant en Polynésie française
et justifiant bien sûr des intérêts
requis à notre avis doit être inférieur
à la durée qui a été prévue par les
auteurs de l'amendement et donc c'est
pour ça que on propose et on est ouvert
à une discussion évidemment avec avec la
commission avec leur rapporteur sur
cette question nous on propose de
diminuer ce délai par rapport à ce qu'il
est prévu actuellement et là en
l'occurrence l'amendement que je vous
présente prévoit de réduire ce délai au
lieu de deux années à un délai de neuf
mois je vous remercie
de 4574
c'est dur hein
oui dans le droit fil des amendements
déposés et présentés par mes collègues
Houlgate et jaumier
cet amendement tend à s'intéresser à la
situation des fonctionnaires de l'État
résidant Polini françaises et évidemment
qui justifierait d'intérêt requis nous
estimons que les auteurs de l'amendement
prévoyant
deux ans pour ce retrait mériterait
d'étudier avec intérêt ce sous
amendement qui lui souhaite diminuer à
un an la période par rapport au
dispositif proposé
mais c'est encore moi
même sujet même
inquiétude
comme je l'ai dit à l'instant et comme
mes collègues Houlgate jaumier d'autres
collègues l'ont exposés cet amendement
pour les fonctionnaires de l'État
résident en polynés françaises et qui
justifie d'intérêt requis propose de
réduire de à 18 mois et non pas à deux
ans la durée prévue initialement dans le
dispositif du projet de loi merci chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur soit
amendement est sous amendement
oui merci effectivement cet amendement
mettre une distinction entre le régime
hexagonal et le régime des Outre-mer il
y a des propositions tout à fait
intéressantes c'est expliquer
effectivement le dispositif iTER est en
voie d'extinction
2028 monsieur le ministre nous précisera
exactement et c'est vrai que
actuellement c'est une majoration de
pensions et qu'il faut le prendre en
compte les
âges les agents anticipés de départ il y
en a déjà énormément cette réforme au
poste beaucoup de temps pour définir
effectivement un article 7 avec un âge
légal qui se décale à 64 ans mais on
passera aussi beaucoup d'articles pour
faire des dérogations et déjà
j'anticiper donc nous ne souhaitons pas
nous le souhaitons pas aller à
l'encontre de la philosophie de cette
réforme qui n'est pas celle d'agent
anticiper mais plutôt un effort
collectif de durée du travail c'est la
raison pour laquelle comme sur les
autres demandes tout à l'heure je après
un avis défavorable et une précision si
vous le permettez Monsieur le monsieur
le
Président les sous amendements
effectivement mérite mérite une étude
approfondie parce que il faut voir
l'impact et en conséquence je ne peux
pas donner
un avis de recevabilité tant que la
Commission ne s'est pas réunie en ce qui
concerne c'est sous amendements donc
avis défavorable sur l'amendement et il
recevabilité sur les sous amendements
merci monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président en réalité sur
ces amendements vous donnez des
explications très générales les
différences de coût de la vie entre les
territoires
ultramarins et métropolitain pour un
sujet très particulier que celui des
fonctionnaires en Polynésie d'abord sur
l'amendement qui vise la différencier
l'effort contributif qui est demandé à
tous les actifs du pays pour un principe
d'équité j'y suis défavorable et ensuite
à travers vos sous amendements vous
abordez en réalité beaucoup de sujets
qui ne sont pas touchés par la réforme
des retraites qu'on est en train de
discuter puisque vous abordez en réalité
deux sujets bien particuliers celui des
intérêts matériels et moraux qui ne sont
absolument pas mis en cause ou toucher
ou impactés par la réforme que nous
sommes en train de discuter et celui de
l'indemnité temporaire de retraite qui
est une indemnité qui est mis en
extinction depuis 2008 qui n'a été
remise en cause par aucun des
gouvernements de toutes les majorités
dont les majorités socialistes dans les
quin ceux qui ont précédé et qui n'a
aucun rapport direct avec la réforme des
retraites sur ces deux sujets ceci dit
pour ne pas répondre à côté j'ai déjà
répondu à une question au gouvernement
sur les intérêts matériels et moraux en
garantissant la bonne application
absolue des matériels hémoraux qui ont
été définis par une jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État extrêmement clairement et
j'ai pris des engagements puisque avec
mon collège Jean-François caraco je
préside effectivement une commission sur
le sujet particulier de l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite que nous
puissions trouver des mécanismes pour
apporter des réponses les élus
ultramarins qui participent à cette
commission elle a été réunie le 17
février dernier sur l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite le savent d'ici
le PLF de cette année nous aurons trouvé
des solutions pour venir trouver un
mécanisme dérogatoire à l'extinction qui
est encore une fois j'insiste sur ce
sujet n'a été remise en cause par aucun
des gouvernements depuis 2008 donc avis
défavorable able sur tous les
amendements et sous amendement merci
monsieur le rapporteur vous lire
préciser quelque chose une petite
précision j'ai fait une erreur j'ai
parlé 10 recevabilités non c'est un avis
personnel défavorable en ce qui concerne
les sous amendements puisqu'ils n'ont
pas été émis étudier en commission merci
merci monsieur Lurel
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
sujet que je soulève depuis le début de
notre discussion ce texte ne tient aucun
compte des réalités outre-mer là vous
évoquez l'ittr l'indemnité temporaire de
retraite c'est pas seulement la
Polynésie c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est Wallis-et-Futuna c'est la Réunion
c'est saint-pierre-et-miqueloy et un
régime un peu spécial pour la ça
n'existe pas en Guadeloupe en Martinique
et en Guyane il y a une mise en
extinction parce qu'il y avait des
fraudes personne n'a compté c'était un
système frauduleux on a donc réparé
résultat les engagements pris en 2008
commencez en 2019 l'État n'a jamais tenu
compte des compensations de
l'intégration des primes dans la société
rémunération et que les économies faites
resteraient dans le territoire résultat
des militaires sont en pauvreté les
fonctionnaires d'État sont en pauvreté
et vous dites ça n'est pas ça impacte et
quand vous avez ici les documents de la
CNAV c'est vrai en Martinique en
Guadeloupe et ailleurs la pension de
retraite en Martinique le régime général
assez 540 euros c'est des carrières
hachées pour obtenir le minimum
contributif il faut 120 trimestres chez
nous on obtient pas sans distrimètre ce
qui fait sa tombe sur les femmes cette
retraite ce projet est kafkaï
surréaliste et ignore et vous nous
invoquez l'IRO solvabilité au nom du
traitement illégal ou différent des
territoires il faut plus de
différenciation pour mieux tenir compte
de réalité c'est faux ce que vous faites
merci chers collègues monsieur Durand
oui monsieur le Président je souscris
aux arguments qui ont été développés par
notre collègue Victoria Lurel juste un
petit point de méthode j'ai bien compris
que que tout ce débat vous agacait
prodigieusement que tout ça allait
beaucoup trop lentement et qu'il fallait
accélérer donc tac vous ne voulez pas de
la main tendue ou de vous offrons pour
vous aider à vous sortir du guêpier dans
lequel vous vous êtes fourré en vous
embarquant dans cette loi aussi mal
fagotée vous ne voulez pas nous nous
laissez vous aider à sortir de
l'impopularité qu'il va falloir assumer
partout dans chaque ville village
préfecture sous préfecture mais si vous
voulez gagner du temps je pense qu'on
gagnerait quand même à avoir des deux
rouleurs qui sont un petit peu
correctement ficelés on a un dérouleur
papier sur lequel n'apparaissent pas les
amendements qu'on vient étudier on a un
tableau électronique qui mentionne des
amendements dans un ordre et on a un
dérouleur numérique qui mentionne un
ordre différent de ce qu'on a là donc un
tout petit peu de méthode nous aidera à
vous aider à aller beaucoup beaucoup
plus vite
merci chers collègues et Madame pour ces
Monges
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez retiré
le recours à lire recevabilité mais en
fait je pense que vous allez peut-être
l'actionner un peu plus tard j'avais
demandé tout à l'heure la parole après
les propos du monsieur de monsieur le
ministre mais vous m'avez pas vu donc
j'en profite pour dire à Monsieur le
Ministre du socle si vous prétendez au
nom de la séparation des pouvoirs ne pas
vous mêler désirsovabilité
décréter notamment par le Sénat
je vous demande d'aller jusqu'au bout et
de vous abstenir de les commenter et
surtout en reprenant les mêmes exemples
que monsieur le rapporteur
en les commentant vous ne respectez pas
la séparation des pouvoirs et beaucoup
plus grave pour vous nous pourrions
croire que vous les avez inspiré
et Monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues défends l'amendement 44
31 monsieur le rapporteur vous avez usé
hier mais on n'a pas eu le temps d'avoir
le débat parce que l'article 38 a été
déclenché autour de l'espérance de vie
et
l'amendement que nous déposons vient ici
et de le contredire nous vivons plus
longtemps donc il faut travailler plus
longtemps j'essaie de ne pas caricaturer
vos propos mais c'était à peu près ça
oui mais monsieur le rapporteur pourquoi
on vit plus longtemps
et oui c'est la question il y a la
question la santé publique qui a
beaucoup progressé la question de la
vaccination la question l'alimentation
du progrès technique la robotisation
notamment au travail qui permet de
gagner de l'espérance de vie et de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et
puis il y a eu des lois
plus protectrices pour les travailleurs
et travailleuses au début du siècle on
travaille 10 heures six jours par
semaine bon ben on a atteint un moment
donné les congés payés la journée des
huit heures et puis évidemment les 35
heures le partage du temps de travail
donc si on revient et qu'on est à rebond
de l'histoire à un moment donné on aura
un problème sur la question l'espérance
de vie deuxième argument si nous gagnons
l'espérance de vie pourquoi le donner
qu'au capital
c'est une question on peut le partager
là aussi à un moment donné avec du temps
libéré des contrats du capital et donc
un droit à la retraite pour être utile
autrement et dernière argument sur
lequel vous n'avez jamais répondu en 5
jours oui oui espérance de vie bien sûr
on travaille moins mais on est beaucoup
plus productif que dans les années 80 là
où elle salarié générée 25000 euros de
travail de valeur il en fait 80 000
aujourd'hui et les gains de productivité
sont passés où dans le travail dans les
salaires dans les pensions
j'aimerais la réponse de monsieur le
rapporteur merci beaucoup chers
collègues donc j'ai été saisi de scrutin
public sur ces sous amendements et sur
l'amendement en lui-même
donc je vais soumettre au scrutin public
le sous amendement 4768 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
vous pouvez rester près des
et les sénateurs qui votent actuellement
dans ce débat sur la réforme des
retraites sur des amendements qui
concernent précisément à des
fonctionnaires résidents en Polynésie
française des amendements qui prévoit
des bonifications de leur droit à la
retraite pour ces fonctionnaires
contenus et bien du coup de la vie
notamment sur le territoire de la
pollinisée de la Polynésie française il
est donc un scrutin public actuellement
à les sénateurs qui votent sur leur
tablette électronique et le vote de
chaque sénateur sera rendu public sur le
site du Sénat sur le site internet du
Sénat des débats donc des amendements
sur les fonctionnaires en Polynésie
après et bien un passage où le dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat puisque la droite
sénatoriale a une nouvelle fois utilisé
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat pour
clôturer les débats sur des amendements
qui concernaient les maire de famille
des amendements qui prévoyaient
de pour ces mères de famille et bien
qu'elle puisse garder les trimestres
gagner grâce à leur parentalité et donc
la clôture de ces débats a forcément mis
en rogne la gauche on écoute le résultat
de ce scrutin public
nombre de votants 344 exprimé 343 pour
93 contre 250 n'est pas adopté sur
sous-amendement 477
le scrutin est ouvert
et pendant que les sénateurs procèdent
au scrutin public sur ces amendements
qui concernent les fonctionnaires
résidents en Polynésie française on va
retrouver Quentin Calmet en tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin on assiste
là dans cette fin d'après-midi à des
débats au Sénat sur courant alternatifs
autour de cette réforme des retraites
oui oui c'est un rythme très étrange
ajoutez à cela les problèmes techniques
sur le fait que tous les Allemands sont
mal affichés entre le site du Sénat et
effectivement les écrans dans
l'hémicycle il en fallait pas moins pour
que et bien les débats soient houleux
dans l'hémicycle déjà que c'est
compliqué avec la gauche sénatoriale qui
a perdu un millier de sous amendements
entre hier et aujourd'hui et qui voit
donc c'est possible de s'opposer à
l'article 7 réduit comme peau de chagrin
plus ajouter à cela depuis quelques
minutes et bien l'utilisation de
l'article 38 qui a été redemandé sur un
amendement par le chef de fil des LR et
donc la limitation du nombre d'orateurs
sur un amendement une personne peut
présenter son amendement deux orateurs
pour et ensuite c'est tout et bien tout
cela ajoute à une forme voilà de tension
qui est présente dans l'hémicycle qui
n'est pas propice au débat sur le fond
je peux vous l'assurer à tout moment on
sent qu'une braise peut enflammer ce
débat alors que effectivement on
commence tout juste à aller sur certains
points techniques du fond voilà on va
écouter effectivement le président de
séance Vincent Delaive qui va pouvoir
proclamer les résultats de ce scrutin
votant 332 exprimé 331 pour 81 contre
250 pas adopté le 477
parce que tu as ouvert
on a voté de ce que tu as éclos
votant 340 4 exprimés 343 pour 93 contre
250 il n'a pas été adopté 4771 de ce
côté est ouvert
et les sénateurs qui poursuivent c'est
votre sur les scrutins publics qui ont
été demandés autour d'amendement qui
concerne et bien l'âge de départ à la
retraite de fonctionnaires résident en
polynés françaises on va retrouver
Quentin calmé en tribune de l'hémicycle
du Sénat quand un rappel nous ce que
c'est inscrit un public dans la
procédure parlementaire oui d'autant que
c'est l'une des dernières armes qu'il
reste en fait encore à la gauche pour
ralentir ces débats tout simplement pour
résumer et bien au lieu de voter à main
levée sur un amendement on voit on va
sur des machines de vote dans
l'hémicycle les machines doit être
électroniques avec ensuite le résultat
qui s'inscrit sur les écrans géants qui
se trouve ici sur les bords sur les murs
qui jouent l'hémicycle comme cela alors
les sénateurs votent tous avec leur
carte électromagnétique ou alors il y a
une délégation de vote qui est accordée
au président des groupes ou un
vice-président qui dans ces cas là
rassemble les cartes magnétiques de tous
les sénateurs membres de son vote et il
se met à d'accord sur qui votre quoi sur
tel amendement tel article et donc avec
la délégation de vote un président ou un
vice-président de groupe va voter pour
l'ensemble du groupe c'est ce qui fait
que l'on a un nombre de votants qui est
bien supérieur au nombre de présence
dans l'hémicycle c'est permis que par le
Règlement du Sénat ça n'existe plus
depuis les années 90 à l'Assemblée
nationale où vous ne pouvez voter que
avec une seule délégation de vote pour
un seul député à votre place et donc ça
c'est ce qui permet au sénateur bien de
s'exprimer avec l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle merci beaucoup Quentin pour
ces explications
contre 25
0 nous passons 4773
est-ce que tu as ouvert
le scrutin est
votant 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 pas adopté 474
voilà et pendant que les sénateurs
votent un public sur ses amendements
j'accueille sur ce plateau David et
Soline bonsoir vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de Paris un mot sur la
reprise de ces débats cet après-midi sur
l'article 7 de la réforme des retraites
il y a toujours beaucoup de tensions
entre la gauche et la droite sénatoriale
bah oui bon d'abord ce qui s'est passé
cette nuit ça laisse des traces mais on
pensait au moins sur les amendements qui
restent en discussion et qui ont été
remis à la discussion par la Commission
elle-même après en avoir élagué des
centaines et des milliers on va dire que
le débat allait quand même avoir lieu
sur ce minimum et sur le premier
amendement du groupe socialiste qui est
qui avait passé
tous ces filtrage on nous remet
l'article 38 qui n'a quasiment jamais
été utilisé au Sénat jusqu'à présent
pour dire il y a juste un pour un conte
et pas de droit d'explication de votre
c'est la démonstration de ce que l'on
disait parce que je vois bien que la
droite est en train de dire j'avais
obstruction parce qu'ils avaient des
centaines d'amendements etc et donc on a
utilisé des moyens de faire que le débat
soit sérieux réel sur l'essentiel mais
là c'est le l'essentiel justement
puisqu'ils ont déjà tout balancé dans la
nuit et il remettent article 38 c'est
incroyable d'autant que à l'Assemblée
nationale l'article 7 beaucoup sont son
offusqué n'a pas été discuté or c'est
l'article de la loi c'est il y a pas de
loi sur cet article c'est c'est c'est là
que on dit qu'on passe à 64 ans ce qui
est l'objet de la contestation ou de des
Français et quand on arrive ici le Sénat
peut sonorer lui d'avoir ce débat parce
que si la loi est adoptée entre
guillemets avec toutes les méthodes
expédiatives du gouvernement faudra bien
quand même cet article et eu un débat
dans une des deux chambres il n'a pas eu
lieu à l'Assemblée
on a eu 50 heures déjà de discussion ici
sur ce qui était disons secondaire dans
la loi même si rien n'est secondaire
mais sur cet article ils sont en train
d'aller à marche forcée et ne pas
vouloir de débat et donc ce n'est pas
pour lutter contre l'abstant
l'obstruction de la gauche que le la
droite est en train d'utiliser ces
méthodes mais bien pour empêcher le
débat sur la tigre fondamental article 7
donc vous reconnaissez qu'il y a une
forme d'obstruction de la gauche c'est
que l'objectif de la gauche inatoriale
c'est d'empêcher un vote final c'est
l'inverse je ne reconnais pas je suis en
train de vous dire que sur l'article 7
sur les chiens je vous ai dit
je vous dis que nous voulons un débat et
un vote sur l'article 7 et un débat
approfondie parce que c'est le ne de
cette réforme d'accord et que c'est
paradoxalement sur cet article que les
foudres se sont déchaînés de la droite
pour empêcher qu'il soit débattus voilà
donc le débat devient quasi insensaire
si aucune des deux assemblées n'a
discuté sur le fond de cet article même
une CMP bon le Conseil constitutionnel
va devoir se pencher sur le fait que le
nœud de cette réforme n'a pas été
délibérément et sincèrement dans les
assemblées après nous on sait que le
gong tombe le dimanche à minuit ça c'est
le gouvernement qui est utilisé cette
cette méthode qui est que notre temps
est contraint il doit s'arrêter là vous
avez ramené pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
votre finale
on va on va tout faire pour se battre et
de faire que cette réforme ne soit pas
adoptée j'ai pas je suis pas
notre objectif c'est que cette loi soit
battue tout simplement mais aujourd'hui
nous empêche de discuter de l'article
phare et c'est ça le sujet d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup David à souligne d'être
venu sur le plateau de Public Sénat
allez on retourne dans l'hémicycle
suivant
si je dépasse légèrement mon temps mais
je n'en suis pas sûr simplement c'est un
ces amendements que ce soit le 4146 et
les quatre suivants reprennent alinéa
para alinéa les durées les durées de
cotisation qui sont augmentées
progressivement par âge de génération en
génération et tant mieux c'est
progressif c'est pas brutalement comme
on peut l'entendre on prend deux ans non
on prend pas deux ans c'est un trimestre
par année de génération ce qui montre
bien qu'il y a une progression alors
effectivement on peut faire des sous
amendements s'opposer à cela et
supprimer être pas d'accord avec ça mais
on peut aussi avoir une technique qui
consiste à liner un paralinéa à proposer
à supprimer les 160 69 trimestres pour
une certaine génération
170 pour une autre génération etc
voyez-vous je pense que c'est pas
forcément ça qui va faire avancer le
débat dès l'instant où vous êtes opposé
et nous y sommes favorables par contre
par contre Monsieur gay m'a posé une
question
qui me semble-t-il est intéressante la
productivité voilà là ça mérite un débat
la productivité en France elle est
meilleure qu'ailleurs et bien qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire que les conditions de
travail sont pas si mauvaises que ça ça
veut dire que nos employeurs ça veut
dire que nos employés nos salariés nos
travailleurs et bien quelque part ils
travaillent mieux que dans les pays
voisins ça mérite d'être souligné quand
même c'est pas le temps boulot misérable
que l'on a parfois entendu ces derniers
jours mais se posent monsieur gay il y a
pas que la productivité il y a également
le problème de la population qui fait un
bassin et les heures travaillées en
France 630 heures par an ramené à
l'habitant le pays voisin madame
chillinger vous le connaissez bien c'est
à quelques centaines de chez vous
940 heures 630 940 on voit bien qu'il y
a des pays qui ont une conception
différente du travail je pense que ça
méritait d'être signalé et comme nous
avons comme nous avons justement pas
suffisamment de production parce que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment d'heures
travaillées pour conforter notre modèle
social il nous appartient de prendre nos
responsabilités c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous demandons cet effort
collectif pour travailler plus
globalement à la fois pour produire
davantage et faire en sorte que nos
jeunes puissent trouver du travail mais
également améliorer l'équilibre de la
réforme des retraites
merci monsieur le Président l'amendement
présenté par Madame pour ce police
supprime un alinéa de l'article il y en
a trois autres qui suivent qui suivent
et qui suppriment les alinés
impressionnants cela remet en cause la
montée en puissance de la réforme des
Touraine donc le Gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement numéro 41
46 comme nous serons des favorables
exactement pour les mêmes raisons pour
les trois suivants je serai plus rapide
madame la sénatrice vous avez vous avez
interpellé en disant la France qui vous
avez lu il se trouve que la France qui
m'a élu c'est une circonscription du
Nord de l'Ardèche et c'est plus
particulier une commune mais vous avez
dit vous avez dit Monsieur le Ministre
donc j'ai bien pensé que vous vous
adressez à moi
et je vous dis simplement madame la
sénatrice que c'est donc une
circonscription au nord de l'Ardèche et
c'est plus particulièrement une commune
qui s'appelle Annonay qui est cher à mon
coeur puisque j'y est né j'ai grandi et
j'y habite et hier de 10h à 15h 10h 15h
un tiers des foyers ont été privés
d'électricité à la suite d'une coupure
sauvage et volontaire dans le cas du
mouvement social sont des écoles
confirmées ce sont des personnes
hospitalisées à domicile
sous-espérateurs quand tu es mise en
danger sont des personnes coincées dans
des ascenseurs ce sont des commerces
fermés des restaurants qui n'ont pas pu
ouvrir c'est à cette France là que je
pense quand j'ai fait cette réforme
[Musique]
monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur de la réponse on
peut continuer à avoir un débat même si
il sera court mais vous avez pas répondu
sur les gains de productivité vous nous
avez répondu sur la pénibilité et il y a
des métiers difficiles moins difficiles
c'est vrai que le travail à l'usine est
moins pénible aujourd'hui qu'il y a 50
ans mais il peut rester des métiers
extrêmement difficiles y compris à
l'usine sur les chantiers j'ai pas vu
beaucoup d'exosquelettes quand j'en
visite mais peut-être demain ou
après-demain ça va exister mais vous
avez pas répondu sur les gains de
productivité
un salarié en 1980 généré 25000 euros de
richesse créée aujourd'hui 80 000 où
sont passés ces gains de productivité ni
dans les salaires ni dans les pensions
de retraite et il y a 10 points donc je
vous réponds 10 points étaient volés par
le capital au travail est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou pas sur le rapporteur non
mais attendez ça c'est pas c'est pas moi
ou le groupe communiste ou l'ensemble de
la gauche c'est les chiffres fondés non
mais je vous dis ça et donc il faut bien
qu'on ait un débat sur cette question où
est la gaine productivité sur la
productivité horaire on vous a déjà
répondu l'ouvrier français et un des
plus productifs y compris par rapport à
l'Allemagne et d'ailleurs c'est le
rapporteur je vous le dis là aussi si
votre vision c'est les jobs à 1 euro et
les travailleurs pauvres c'est pas la
nôtre et si votre vision c'est d'avoir
des retraités pauvres comme en Allemagne
ou contrairement à la France où il y a
déjà trop c'est trop 10% de retraité
pauvre mais 21,5 en Allemagne si c'est
ça la société dans laquelle vous voulez
vivre pour nous c'est non je vous le dis
donc c'est le rapporteur je vous demande
de re répondre à la question pour vous
où sont passés les gains de productivité
et comment mieux les partager je vous
remercie petit chers collègues et le
président Patriat demande la parole
c'est le Président je vous remercie je
demande l'application de l'article 38 un
pour rencontre
donc j'ai une demande d'application
d'article 38 à nouveau donc il y a un
orateur pas gros qui peut s'exprimer
un orateur pas gros
mais est-ce que ça signifie je suis
conte bien sûr 38 qu'on va pas pouvoir
commenter ce qui a été dit précédemment
bon alors moi je vais les commenter du
coup voilà alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez du mal à voir qui fera 2 ans
de plus bon alors je vous dis les femmes
les femmes à 62 ans pile à 62 ans pile
sont plus nombreuses que les hommes à
liquider leur retraite elles sont 35%
35% des femmes liquides leur retraite à
62 ans pile pour ces 35% de femmes ces
deux enferment
je vous ai déjà signalé mais bon que à
61 ans une personne sur deux plus d'une
personne sur deux n'est pas en emploi
n'est plus en emploi mais
au minimum sociaux au chômage de longue
durée en maladie de longue durée en
inactivité quelquefois sans ressources
cela à 61 ans c'est pour eux ils
pouvaient partir à 62 ans sortir de ces
minimas pour liquider leur retraite pour
eux ces deux ans ferment
c'est ça qu'il faut quand on regarde
productivité j'ai peut-être pas le temps
mais ils sont quand on voit l'intensité
de travail etc quelques fois ils sont
faits sur une base d'intensification du
travail et de souffrance au travail donc
ils sont pas tous vertueux les gains de
productivité
merci pour ces moments
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres chers collègues juste je
défends cette amendement mais juste pour
revenir sur les gains de productivité il
est évident que on l'a déjà dit que que
cette retraite par répartition elle est
aussi elle doit être aussi la
répartition de la richesse produite par
le travail et d'ailleurs je sais plus si
c'est Michel Édouard Leclerc qui a dit à
un moment donné qu'il faudrait taxer les
robots parce que si on pousse à
l'extrême dans l'hypothèse où on est une
société totalement automatisée et où il
n'y a plus personne qu'il cotise parce
que personne ne travaille ou n'est
productif c'est une situation absurde
mais mais il faut se poser la question
de savoir justement sur où sont répartis
les gains de productivité je reviens sur
je reviens sur l'amendement en question
pourquoi nous le soutenons tout
simplement parce que cette réforme elle
est brutale elle est brutale elle génère
des frustrations et on l'a vu s'il y a
une s'il y a une mobilisation de cette
ampleur c'est aussi parce que les gens
sont frustrés pourquoi le sont-il tout
simplement parce que les gens qui sont
nés en 1961 il se projette et il se
projette d'autant plus qu'il reçoive
régulièrement est-ce qu’on appelle le
relevé individuel de situation et on l'a
tous reçu se relever individuel de
situation et en plus à côté de ce relevé
individuel de situation et bien on
reçoit ce qu'on appelle une Estimation
Indicative Globale et bien avec ça les
gens se projettent ils se disent ben oui
il me reste encore temps de trimestre à
faire et peut-être même que je dois
faire un peu plus compte tenu de
l'ajustement que je fais par rapport à
cette Estimation Indicative Globale
parce que c'est pas suffisant et que je
serai amené à me caler peut-être un peu
plus longtemps mais toujours est-il que
que les gens se projettent et à partir
du moment où de façon brutale on leur
dit ben écoutez vous allez travailler un
trimestre deux ou trois de plus et bien
elle vit évidemment ça génère des
frustrations parce que les gens ont des
projets individuels alors se posent la
question se pose la question du rapport
au travail mais j'aurais eu l'occasion
de leur développer dans d'autres
interventions il chers collègues
je vais mettre aux voix donc
l'application de l'article 38 qui est
pour l'application d'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté et donc
nous passons au vote et j'ai une demande
de scrutin public de la part du groupe
CCE sur l'amendement 4146 avec deux avis
défavorables donc il va être procédé ce
que tu as publié que le scrutin est
ouvert
Chine les sénateurs qui continuent le
débat sur l'article 7 de cette réforme
des retraites un article qui porte l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
et c'est aussi un article qui accélère
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
elle était prévue depuis la réforme
torrent souffrances Hollande et bien à
43 annuités en 2035 et cette réforme des
retraites prévoient de passer ces 43 ans
nuités à
2027 donc une accélération de
l'augmentation et ces amendements
communistes qui sont en train d'être
votés par scrutin public en ce moment
justement il supprime cette accélération
de l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation allez on va retrouver Quentin
calmer en tribune dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat au Quentin l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat a été une nouvelle
fois utilisée mais cette fois-ci par un
sénateur de la majorité présidentielle
exactement alors que les amendements des
communistes viennent d'être rejetés et
que donc c'est la gauche qui s'opposait
à cette accélération de la réforme
Touraine est en train de perdre les
arbitrage par le vote on va écouter
Laurence Cohen effectivement puisque
maintenant il y a l'article 38 qui est
aussi demandé par François patriar va
suivre ça de très près 1963 c'est un peu
ce qu'a dit notre notre rapporteur qui a
bien compris le sens de nos amendements
en 2013 nous avons combattu la réforme
Touraine au niveau du groupe communiste
nous considérons naturellement son
accélération comme l'approfondissement
d'une logique mortifère pour les
travailleurs et les travailleuses en
portant la durée de cotisation à 170
trimestres dès la génération 1963 vous
ne prenez pas en compte les réalités du
travail il existe pour de nombreux
Français français une zone grise plus ou
moins longue très inconfortable où les
femmes et les hommes ne sont ni en
emploi ni à la retraite c'était le cas
de près de 16,7% des personnes âgées de
62 ans en 2021 dont 3% étaient au
chômage et 13,7% en inactivité et
dépendait essentiellement du RSA d'une
pension d'invalidité ou du revenu de
leur conjoint le taux d'emploi des plus
de 60 ans est faible 35,5 % contre 46,4
% au sein de l'Union européenne plus on
avance on âge moins on a de chance
d'avoir un emploi surtout si on n'a pas
décroché de titre scolaire là je
constitue avec le sexe le premier motif
déclaré des expériences de
discrimination liées au travail loin
devant l'origine ethnique pointait en
2018 France stratégie allongez donc la
durée de cotisation ne peut que
pénaliser l'ensemble des travailleurs de
la génération de 1963 d'où la
suppression de l'alinéa et monsieur le
Président vous avez vu j'ai pas joué sur
le chrono qui s'était pas déclenché
merci même quand
monsieur rapporteur vous avez donné un
avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre aussi il y a deux
avis défavorables donc j'ai saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur cet
amendement par le groupe RCE
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
expliqué en
argumentant sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements que c'était après tout
l'application strict de l'accélération
de la durée de cotisation circuler il y
a rien à voir moi je voudrais vous
parler d'un cas particulier qui montre
en effet la brutalité de cette réforme
je vais vous parler d'un jardinier qui
travaille dans la une ville de
Seine-Maritime qui est dirigé par un
ancien Premier ministre qui est
favorable à la retraite à 67 ans je
pense que vous suivez que vous
identifiez ce jardinier l'exerce depuis
81 il est exposé aux postures pénibles
aux risques chimiques au vibrations au
gestes répétitif et me dit-il à
l'accroissement des surfaces à traiter
puisqu'il y a visiblement eu dans cette
ville des réductions d'effectifs
lorsqu'il contact la RH en charge des
retraites il apprend qu'une personne née
en juin 63 peut bénéficier du dispositif
carrière longue mais que lui qui est né
en septembre 63 va devoir travailler 9
mois de plus j'ai rencontré ce jardinier
dans une manifestation parce qu'il
portait une pancarte où était indiquée
42 ans de bonnes conduite 9 mois ferme
et donc les amendements que nous
proposons tout en vous le savez nous
contestons fondamentalement
l'allongement et l'accélération de la
durée de cotisation mais il y a des
situations par particulier qui
mériteraient d'être prises en compte
parce que des gens se retrouvent dans
des situations extrêmement difficiles
dans les prochains mois merci chers
collègues donc je mets au vote cet
amendement j'ai une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe CRCE sur cet
amendement 4149 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à voter sur
des amendements sur l'article 7 de la
réforme des retraites qui allongent
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite et
qui accélèrent l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation on va retrouver
Quentin calmer faites-nous un petit
point sur les débats sur cet article 7
effectivement c'est des bases sur
l'article 7 qui ont repris après les
questions d'actualité c'était à 16h30
avec un faux rythme depuis 16h30 on a
beaucoup des bêtises au début et bien de
la perte de ses amendements par la
gauche hier en séance ensuite on discute
un peu sur le fond puis ensuite on
discute à nouveau sur la méthode car et
bien l'intervalle régulier on voit
d'abord monsieur Retailleau puis ensuite
François Patriat pour les marcheurs du
Sénat demandez l'utilisation de
l'article 38 qui contraint le nom de
prise de parole dans la défense ou dans
l'opposition un amendement donc il est à
la fois un débat sur le fond mais qui
est entrecoupé avec un débat sur la
méthode et c'est des vacances
effectivement par le Règlement du Sénat
retour au débat
je peux partir au même âge à 58 et avec
43 nuités si je commence à travailler à
16 ans je peux partir à 60 ans mais avec
44 à lui t mais si c'est 17 ans c'est
toujours 60 ans mais avec 43 nuitées
bref et ça s'enchaîne comme ça jusqu'à
l'âge de 21 ans et donc on a du mal à
voir comment vous avez construit ce
tableau et qu'est-ce qu'il y a de juste
à ce que lorsqu'on a travaillé à
travailler à 14 c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose qu'à 15 et pourquoi il faut
que je cotise plus pour partir au même
âge je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
simplement je vais mettre un avis
défavorable et symbole exemple parce que
actuellement votre personne qui a
travaillé avant 16 ans si elle a
catastrophe avant la fin de ses 16 ans
elle va partir combien quelle est la
durée de cotisation quelle est la durée
de cotisation d'art + 2 d'art + 2 ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire 45 ans ça
c'est l'application de la loi actuelle
qui a voté cette loi
pardon pas vous vous avez voté cette loi
qu'est-ce qu'il est proposé dans la loi
qui vient que ces personnes qui ont
catalyse un trimestre avant la fin de la
saison de la fin de l'année de leur
saison excusez moi puisse travailler
moins longtemps et on aura l'occasion de
discuter avec ça c'est l'article 8 parce
qu'effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'inégalités parce que un mois
près vous tapez la bande suivante et en
conséquence vous prenez effectivement la
2 ans ça mérite un débat voilà ça mérite
un débat on l'aura dans l'article 8
vivement qu'on y soit l'article 8
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
c'est un avis défavorable que j'ai déjà
exprimé j'ajoute à ce que dit monsieur
le rapporteur que pour pouvoir partir
dans le cadre des dispositifs carrière
longue il suffit pas d'avoir quatre ou
cinq trimestres cotisés avant la
dernière jour de l'année civile de vos
saisons de vos 18 ans demain ou de vos
20 ans il faut avoir les quatre à cinq
trimestres cotisées avant la borne d'âge
il faut attendre l'âge d'ouverture des
droites telles que prévu par la loi
c'est-à-dire 58 ans si vous avez
commencé avant 16 ans dans la loi
aujourd'hui et il faut par ailleurs
avoir atteint la durée de cotisation
requise en l'état de la loi la Dar + 2
intégralement cotisée sans tenir compte
des trimestres qui ne serait que valider
et cotisés ce qui explique qu'entre les
principes de départ au titre des
carrières longues et la bonification
effective il y a un écart parce que bien
souvent dans la carrière des uns et des
autres tous les tous les trimestres
arrivaient à l'âge légal ne sont pas des
trimestres cotisées mais une partie
peuvent être validées le service
militaire par exemple et ce qui explique
les décalages ce qui rend assez
inopérant pardon le dire comme ça les
comparaisons de Data ou d'anniversaire à
anniversaire puisqu'en réalité ça
renvoie au parcours de vie de chacun
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe CSE sur cet amendement
4285 avec deux avis défavorables il va
être procédé au scrutin public le
scrutin
est ouvert
et les sénateurs qui continuent à voter
et à discuter de l'article 7 de cette
réforme des retraites un article qui je
le rappelle augmente l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans et puis autre mesure
dans cette article 7 il accélère la
réforme Touraine qui avait été votée
sous François Hollande c'est une réforme
qui est augmentée progressivement la
durée de cotisation nécessaire jusqu'en
2035 pour attendre pour atteindre 43 à
nuités et cette réforme dans le second
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et bien
elle accélère cette augmentation de la
durée de cotisation pour atteindre à C43
à nuités en 2027 et là ce que propose
des sénateurs communistes avec leurs
amendements c'est d'exonérer de cette
augmentation de durée de cotisation
certaines générations notamment dans les
années 1960 il y en avait défavorable on
entendu du gouvernement et de la
commission alors que le scrutin public
est bientôt clos sur ce nouvel
amendement communiste autour de la durée
de cotisation alors on le rappelle il y
a un petit un petit jeu de procédure la
gauche qui est multiplie les scrutins
publiques pour rallonger un petit peu
les débats on écoute le résultat 344
exprimé 1943 pour 93 contre 250 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté nous passons 4286 qui le
défend
allez-y madame
merci monsieur le Président à l'instant
nous avons échangé en vue de la
suppression de l'article 7 qui est le
cœur de votre contre-réforme sociale à
défaut d'avoir pu supprimer tout cet
article nous nous attacherons donc à
retirer le du texte ce qui nous semble
le plus problématique l'allongement de
l'âge légal de départ en retraite les
alinéasités dans notre amendement sont
précisément ce qui décaleront demain
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans pour pouvoir
partir en retraite et partant de là
allongeront pour tous les Français les
carrières de deux ans on a eu l'occasion
d'en discuter longuement mais selon les
chiffres de la DARES publiés en janvier
2023 pour l'année 2021 le constat est
infligent malgré six ans au pouvoir
votre gouvernement n'a pas réussi à
enrayer le chômage des 55 ans et plus
aujourd'hui la frontière des 60 ans se
matérialise par une chute d'activité de
68% à 59 ans vers 43% à 61 ans pour
atteindre 16% à 64 ans en reculant l'âge
les légales de la retraite vous créez
une trappe de pauvreté dont les Français
de plus de 55 ans qui perdent leur
emploi ne pourront pas s'en sortir la
réforme de l'indemnisation invalidité
joue elle aussi contre les travailleurs
je ne citerai qu'un seul exemple celui
d'un couple de boulanger de mon
département elle a un cancer lui a des
problèmes cardiaques après des années à
maintenir coûte que coûte une activité
ils ont fini par vendre leur atelier or
avec les nouveaux modes de calcul des
pensions d'invalidité il ne touche plus
que 900 euros à deux
âgé de 58 et 60 ans comment vont-ils
vivre ces prochaines années
qu'auront-ils comme retraite comme tous
les artisans et commerçants de notre
pays leur outil de travail et le
patrimoine de toute une vie il pensait
l'utiliser fièrement pour l'avenir de
leur enfant les études des petits
enfants et bien non comme de nombreux
travailleurs qui ont réussi à mettre un
peu de côté votre réforme va les
dévaliser et pendant ce temps-là les
fraudeurs aux cotisations sociales les
év Adés fiscaux les profiteurs de la
crise dorment sur leurs deux oreilles
reculez
monsieur le rapporteur avis défavorable
favorable à l'amendement nous aurons
l'occasion à l'article 8 de parler des
invalidité très bien monsieur le
ministre même avis même avis donc
monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues une des
questions là aussi que sur lequel vous
n'avez pas répondu on vient d'avoir le
débat enfin on n'a pas eu de réponse
aucun de productivité on essaie de
continuer à prendre argument par
argument parce que un débat c'est ça on
pose une question vous répondez on se
rencontre argument on épuise le truc
voilà et puis à un moment donné il y en
a un qui marque un point bon pour
l'instant on n'a pas été au bout quoi
bon on a marqué beaucoup de poèmes bon
mais c'est vous qui maîtrisez le match
sur comme ça mais nous on respecte le
règlement voilà la lettre une des
questions une des questions monsieur le
rapporteur c'est que vous allez décaler
la borne de l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans
et donc c'est une question vous allez le
mettre et le placer sur l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé et une des questions
sur lesquelles il faut parler et à
partir de la réalité du vécu des gens
c'est pas grave à chaque fois qu'on
parle du véhicule des gens j'entendais
ah mais on est bien là pour parler du
vécu des gens et donc quand on déplace
la borne de 62 à 64 ans qui est la borne
de l'espérance de vie en bonne santé ça
veut dire qu'ensemble enfin nous non
mais vous faites le choix de placer la
borne pour la moitié des gens ils
partiront pas à la retraite en bonne
santé et c'est quand même une question
pour nous nous pensons qu'après une dure
vie de labeur et le travail source
d'émancipation et les insociable mais
aussi de souffrance physique et
psychique on pense qu'il faut vivre une
retraite pendant des années au moins en
bonne santé parce que si on place la
borne au moment de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé on connaît un certain nombre
de personnes notamment de métier où les
gens ils ne profitent pas la retraite
parce que on ne profite pas qu'on tombe
malade de suite et qu'après pendant deux
ans on est entre les rendez-vous
médicaux et l'hôpital donc il faut bien
qu'on ait ce débat là je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci cher
collègue le président rénal
oui moi je reconnais que ces évocations
de personnes touchées par les réformes
sont difficiles à entendre on le
comprend bien mais en même temps c'est
bien ça la réalité et ce débat est
passionnant de ce point de vue là il
faut effectivement sortir ici de la
théorie il faut voir ce que nous faisons
et comment ça se traduit pour les uns
pour les autres et nous devons tous me
semble-t-il l'accepter et plutôt écouter
ces témoignages et vous faire votre
propre opinion alors je voudrais revenir
sur un propos du rapporteur tout à
l'heure qui m'a un peu surpris va faire
un lien un peu direct un peu trop direct
entre la productivité et l'idée que si
les Français avaient une forte
productivité c'était qu'il était pas si
mal au travail c'était un drôle de un
drôle de lien tout de même je voudrais
j'ai recherché depuis quelques éléments
mais que je retrouvais facilement avec
ça heureusement on trouve tout alors
l'enquête heureux find sur les
conditions de travail en Europe qui a
été réalisée qui est réalisé d'ailleurs
chaque année et auprès de 71 000
personnes en 2021 mais la France en
queue de peloton parmi les 36 pays sous
vus presque 40% des actifs en emploi
chez nous se trouve dans un emploi
détendu où les exigences sont plus
élevés que les ressources permettant de
répondre à celle-ci et mes chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur parce
que vous avez sans doute pas lu cette
étude on est au niveau sur ces sujets là
on est au niveau de l'Albanie de la
Slovaquie de la Pologne je dis pas que
ce sont pas des exemples je me prononce
pas mais je le mets sur le débat quand
même et je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
faire ce lien un peu rapide entre
productivité et plaisir d'être au
travail
merci monsieur le Président Madame
conseil Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors j'ai
bien entendu
la fébrilité de monsieur le rapporteur
qu'on a à l'article 8 très certainement
pour parler de quelques mesures que vous
proposez mais nous sommes à l'article 7
et l'article 7 il dit que la quasi
majorité des départs anticipés sont des
départs
rendus possibles par la mobilisation du
C2P c'est à dire par par la pénibilité
et de moins en moins par les carrières
longues c'est à dire quand on a commencé
ou super long comme vous le voulez et
dans l'article enfin par l'article 7 ce
départ anticipé il est retardé de deux
ans là aussi ces deux enfermes monsieur
le rapporteur effectivement si vous avez
quelques améliorations il faut pas trop
sauter trop vite à l'article 8 pour dire
les petites mesures d'accompagnement que
vous allez faire mais déjà constater
acter les départs anticipés pour
pénibilité par deux ans plus tard quant
à la validité permanente si on a des
propositions si vous avez des
propositions pour l'instant nous sommes
d'accord rien n'a changé ils partent à
62 ans toujours dans la loi c'est pour
ça monsieur le ministre que je vous dis
que les 3 milliards que vous mettez en
mesure d'accompagnement n'ont pas lieu
d'être puisque c'est le maintien d'un
dispositif mais par contre Monsieur le
Ministre puisque vous avez fait tout
votre équilibre financier en comptant un
dumant ces 3 milliards sans alors que
c'est maintenu je vous propose de passer
l'invalidité permanente à 60 ans auquel
cas vous pouvez remettre les 3 milliards
100 en mesure d'accompagnement merci
Monsieur Houlgate
les différents amendements qui nous ont
été proposés portent sur les personnes
qui sont nées entre 1961 et 1965 ça
tombe bien je veux dire dans la majorité
des gens qui sont ici ça nous concerne
c'est un peu notre génération cette
génération 61-65 d'une certaine façon
dans le monde du travail a connu je
dirais des évolutions c'était la fin des
30 glorieuses ça a été les nombreuses
restructurations et ça a été les
évolutions parmi les nombreuses
restructurations moi je vous invite pour
ceux qui aiment la littérature à lire
les livres de Nicolas Mathieu notamment
leurs enfants après eux et Connemara
qu'est-ce que dit Nicolas Mathieu il
fait le descriptif de ses enfants un peu
perdus de la génération de ceux qui ont
perdu leur travail avec les
restructurations en Lorraine et il
montre combien sont leurs difficultés et
combien justement ils ont dû à travers
le travail essayer de surmonter ces
difficultés ces difficultés elles sont
aussi
conséquente à des mutations donc le
développement de l'automatisation de la
numérisation et ainsi de suite on a
commencé à parler dans le monde du
travail de risque psychosociaux et il
faut souligner que c'est la loi du 17
janvier 2002 Martine Aubry qui a
introduit la notion de santé mentale
dans le code du travail ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que d'une certaine
façon c'est une génération je veux pas
dire que c'est une génération qui a été
sacrifiée mais c'est une génération qu'a
vécu une profonde mutation du monde du
travail et qui en était elle-même
profondément marquée et peut-être
peut-être un peu meurtri donc cette
génération prononce en garde moi je dans
les manifestations et on l'a retrouvé
d'ailleurs dans un article de
Ouest-France ou quelqu'un disait
peut-être à travers ce mal au travail
sur lequel on a beaucoup pris les choses
en considération mais il a dit moi ma
vie professionnelle ça a été un marathon
et bien j'ai l'impression que on a
reculé la ligne d'arrivée de ce marathon
alors on peut le déplorer il y a des
choses qui ont été faites mais faisons
attention à cette génération sacrifiée
61 65 si Madame linman
comment elle s'appelle
est assez proche du niveau moyen des
revenus de les revenus des Français bien
que depuis deux trois ans c'est déjà
baissé et là on va atteindre des choses
terribles puisque on va retrouver des
retraités pauvres je vous donne les
chiffres c'est au lieu d'être à 5 ans à
égalité ce ratio ne serait donc plus de
100% mais de 89% en 2050
94% en 2070 donc de toute façon ce qui
est vrai c'est pourquoi nous avons mené
des produits amendements sur les
recettes c'est que dans le système
actuel si on veut rééquilibrer les
retraites il y aura quand même besoin de
recettes
merci chers collègues président madurée
devant la parole merci monsieur le
Président je sur cette amendement je
demande l'application de l'article 38
1 qui avait intervenir contre même
venir contre
[Musique]
sur l'application
vous devez intervenir pour votre groupe
contre
je fais pas expliquer ça allez-y madame
qui vient d'être formulée je pense que
ce soir et dans les heures qui viennent
il va falloir s'attendre à avoir ces
demandes récurrentes pour nous empêcher
pour nous empêcher d'en véritablesment
dans un débat de fond un débat sérieux
toutes les interventions qui se sont
tenues jusqu'à maintenant sont des
interventions sérieuses fondées
argumenté et donc je ne vois pas vous
avez le droit effectivement d'activer au
titre du Règlement du Sénat de demander
d'activer certains articles 38 mais vous
imaginez bien que nous y sommes
totalement opposés et que là encore une
fois encore une fois vous bafouez
véritablement le rôle du Sénat c'est une
atteinte à la démocratie que d'autres et
que à l'extérieur parce qu'on nous
regarde à l'extérieur on nous regarde
nous écoute à l'extérieur et quand on
verra que lorsqu'on s'engage sur ses
débats et sur ses amendements qui ont
été déposés absolument justifier parce
qu'ils sont même sur le fond même et le
déclinaison très précise à
concrétisation de ce recul d'âge pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui vont
voir les conséquences dès cette année
dès l'année prochaine et non pas dans
les années à venir sur les conséquences
de cette réforme brutale de propositions
de recul d'âge merci monsieur benaroche
merci monsieur le Président en fait
depuis un moment j'essaye de comprendre
à quel moment les articles 38 vont être
demandés j'ai pensé à des tas de
critères je me suis dit finalement c'est
assez logique je pourrais être défenseur
de de et demander moi-même d'ailleurs
l'application d'articles 38 à partir du
moment où nous avons affaire à des
débats sans aucune tenue sans aucune
valeur ou aucun argument n'est développé
où chacun d'entre nous n'apprend rien ou
ceux qui nous regardent sur Public Sénat
ou sur les chaînes de télé n'apprennent
rien de la loi sur les retraites or ce
n'est pas le cas donc je me dis c'est
pas le critère puisqu'en fait moi-même
j'apprends beaucoup de choses en
écoutant mes collègues de tout bord
d'ailleurs lorsqu'ils veulent bien
donner à certains nobles d'arguments et
non pas être sur des postures donc je me
suis dit si c'est pas ça qui fait que
l'article 38 est utilisé c'est sûrement
parce qu'il y a une autre raison
alors la raison c'est quoi la raison en
fait me semble-t-il mais je me trompe
peut-être il faudrait faire une étude
statistique je m'excuse vous avez
demandé l'article 38 j'ai le droit
d'exprimer ce que je pense vous n'êtes
pas obligé de le couper voilà donc je me
suis dit c'est une autre raison quelle
est cette raison et en faisant une
petite étude sur les deux fois où vous
l'avez utilisé par rapport au fond vous
ne l'avez pas utilisé on verra si c'est
confirmé par l'effet dans le futur il me
semble en fait que vous l'utilisez mais
peut-être me trompe à partir du moment
où vous estimez que le débat devient
suffisamment intéressant et appuie à
certains ordre d'arguments auxquels vous
ne souhaitez pas répondre puisque vous
ne voulez pas prolonger le débat vous
avez les réponses vraisemblablement je
suis persuadé que vous avez des réponses
pour argumenter contre les arguments qui
ont été proposés mais vous ne pouvez pas
les donner puisque c'est votre règle ne
pouvant pas les données vous décidez
d'écourter le débat parce qu'il est
argumenté et vous les courtiers en
posant l'article 38 si je me trompe
dites-le moi chers amis mais je pense
que je suis dans le vrai si chers
collègues madame Lindeman
chers collègues on pouvait pas dire que
le débat qui était engagé sur ce sujet
était pas un débat intéressant parce
qu'on était au coeur du débat sur le
niveau des pensions
du débat sur le l'effet de seuil de
changement qui est toujours un problème
politique pour tout le monde quand il y
a une réforme et là bâclé le discussion
Bacri les effets de réflexion alors vous
savez qu'est-ce que ça révèle chers
collègues quand on est embarrassé quand
on sait qu'on est en décalage avec le
peuple et ben on essaie de faire ça vite
fait ni vu ni connu à la sauvette alors
quand monsieur Macron que les amis de
Lorraine nous explique il faut aller
plus vite on a l'habitude chers
collègues ils passent son temps à nous
dire qu'il y a trop de parlementaires
que le Parlement ça va trop vite qu'on
veut qu'on fait toujours des procédures
d'urgence à la limite je dirais c'est
leur culture de contournement du
Parlement mais vous la majorité
sénatoriale elle est a priori ça ne
devrait pas être votre culture alors que
vous soyez un peu agacé parce que nous
avons la force de nos arguments
j'appelle le comprendre mais vous
devriez comprendre que nous concitoyens
attendent de vous des explications des
réponses à nos arguments de faire
entretenir le débat mais vous avez peur
de l'opinion publique vous ne vous
sentez pas fort pour les renforcer et sa
justifie votre votre stratégie décourtée
le débat merci chers collègues donc je
vais mettre aux voix l'application de
l'article 38 qui a été demandé qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc l'article 38
s'applique et donc nous allons passer au
vote j'étais saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe CRCE sur
cet amendement 4286 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à voter sur
des scrutins publiques concernant des
amendements déposés par la gauche sur
cet article 7 article majeur de cette
réforme des retraites article qui
reportent progressivement légal de
départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans et
un article qui est également accéléré
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
pour atteindre 43 habitants en 2027 on
écoute le résultat de ce que tu es en
public
nombre de votants 344 exprimés 343 pour
93 contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons à trois amendements
identiques le 1895 la présidente de la
oui merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues l'article
l3514-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
créé par la réforme des retraites de
2003 prévoit un mécanisme de rachat
d'année d'études pour les assurer
salariés depuis 2003 les assurés peuvent
donc ainsi racheter jusqu'à 12
trimestres d'assurance vieillesse au
titre des années d'études supérieures le
tarif du rachat qui varie selon l'âge et
le niveau de revenu et déterminé selon
un principe de neutralité actuelle c'est
à dire qu'il pèse intégralement sur son
bénéficiaire si ce versement est pris en
compte dans le calcul d'une retraite
classique les trimestres ainsi rachetés
ne sont pas retenus dans le cadre de
dispositifs de retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue ou pour les travailleurs
handicapés il nous faut donc corriger ce
point tout comme le mécanisme mis en
place par la réforme des retraites de
2014 qui a établi un tarif préférentiel
de rachat trimestre pour certains
assurés notamment les apprentis au titre
des périodes d'apprentissage du 1er
juillet 1972 au 31 décembre 2013 car il
cotisait sur une assiette forfaitaire
trop faible pour leur permettre de
valider une durée d'assurance vieillesse
égale à celle de leur contrats nous
souhaiterions donc que les assurer ne
soient pas pénalisés par l'absence de
prise en compte de ces versements dans
le cadre d'un départ anticipé pour
carrière longue ou en tant que
travailleur handicapés aussi nous
proposons que ces versements soient
désormais pris en compte tant dans la
période cotisée que pour apprécier la
condition de début d'activité au titre
du dispositif de retraite pour carrière
longue je vous remercie
de 1909 identique monsieur lévrier
merci monsieur le Président comme ça a
été indiqué précédemment c'est
amendement visa permettre la prise en
compte dans le cadre d'un départ
anticipé pour carrière longue ou en tant
que travailleur handicapé les trimestres
d'apprentissage effectués avant 2014 et
racheté à tarif réduit c'est pour nous
une question de justice sociale que
d'assurer que tous les citoyens ayant eu
un statut d'apprenti puisse obtenir
l'avantage leur trimestre
d'apprentissage et parce que je crois
profondément à l'apprentissage que je
crois profondément à ces jeunes qui
choisissent cette filière et tout
particulièrement à ceux qui ont subi des
accidents de la vie c'est pourquoi je
tiens à vous présenter cet amendement
déjà porté à l'Assemblée nationale et
qu'il me tient particulièrement à cœur
je vous remercie et le 3403 identique
madame pour ces Monges
oui monsieur le président
en préalable je tiens à exprimer mon
émotion
pour défendre un des 17 amendements qui
ont survécu
après le sous amendement je ne parle
même pas de ceux qui n'avaient même pas
survécu
à dire recevabilité en commission dans
un premier temps mais j'avais 157
amendements qui avaient trouvé qui était
paraît-il recevable et il s'en est plus
que 17 donc c'est un grand moment
d'émotion
donc je peux pas mettre cette digression
parce que c'est un petit peu la même
chose donc l'article 27 de la loi du 20
janvier 2014 qui a ouvert la possibilité
pour certaines catégories d'assurés par
dérogation au principe de neutralité
actuelle de bénéficier d'une diminution
du coude de leur versement c'est
notamment le cas vous l'avez dit pour
les apprentis dont le nombre a récemment
explosé comme vous le savez tous fin
2022 la DARES sont dénombrées 980 000
soit près d'un million et il faut bien
préciser qu'il faut
l'essentiel de l'amélioration des
statistiques de l'emploi avec les
radiations mais c'est un autre mécanisme
donc il faut donc pouvoir garantir à ses
assurés qui ne soient pas pénalisés par
l'absence de prise en compte des
versements évoqués
dans le cas et notamment dans le cadre
effectivement d'un départ anticipé pour
carrière longue ou en tant que
travailleur handicapé le contraire
serait injuste d'autant que précisément
leur carrière commence très tôt en
conséquence notre amendement vise à ce
que ces derniers soient désormais pris
en compte dans la période cotisée les
rendant par ce fait éligibles au titre
du dispositif de retraite pour carrière
longue il s'agit donc enfin d'une mesure
de justice et d'une mesure de bon sens
oui merci d'avoir effectivement
posé ces amendements parce que il y
avait
une anomalie quand même que ces
trimestres justement d'apprentis soit
pas pris en compte à la fois dans la
durée mais aussi dans le calcul derrière
de la carrière et notamment pour les
carrières longues
véritablement la carrière longue c'est
vers les apprentis que c'est décidé ceux
qui commencent de bonheur
c'est pas pour ceux qui sont me
semble-t-il plus loin il se rapporte
d'un dispositif commun vraiment de 16-18
ans c'est 15 même 15 18 ans c'est
vraiment là qu'on a besoin de prendre en
compte les apprentis et donc
ça montre bien la différence mes chers
collègues de calcul entre la carrière
longue on prend que les trimestres
cotisés ou réputés cotisés dans le
calcul des 43 ans qu'il y aura à faire
mais 43 ans c'est une carrière normale
faudra qu'on en parle c'est pas une
carrière longue c'est la carrière
normale maintenant et les 43 ans pour
les autres qui s'appliquent après à
partir de 20 ans ou à l'intérieur de ces
43 ans vous avez les trimestres cotisés
réputés cotisées assimilés et les
majorations de pension quand il s'agit
de maire de famille donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une différence de traitement
mais il était nécessaire merci monsieur
le ministre d'avoir aussi la même
réflexion il était nécessaire de le
prendre en compte je vous réponds bien
volontiers parce que ça ça répond de
l'article 7 les questions précédentes
raymondel le sait bien quand même le C2P
c'est pas certain article là et Madame
Liman elle sait bien aussi que les
petits pensions c'est l'article 10 donc
les réponses on les fera en fonction des
articles si on arrive à clarifier ce
débat comme ça je pense qu'on peut
éviter de sortir l'article 38 non donc
on clarifie le débat et on fait en sorte
que les questions qui se posent elles se
posent au bon moment si vous en êtes
d'accord bien entendu donc
[Applaudissements]
un amendement déposé par la député
Christine Le Nabour qui n'a pas pu être
examiné à l'Assemblée et comme cela a
été dit par les différents intervenants
cela va permettre d'intégrer dans les
périodes prises en compte pour
l'éligibilité au départ anticipé au
titre des carrières longues les
trimestres effectués en apprentissage et
tout particulièrement ceux qui ont fait
l'objet d'un rachat de trimestre au
tarif préférentiels qui sont prévus pour
les rachats de trimestre donc c'est une
mesure du de justice et le gouvernement
il est favorable et Monsieur le GATT
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers puisqu'on en est au stade
des questions moi j'ai une question à
poser à René Paul Savary puisqu'on parle
beaucoup des des apprentis et à juste
titre donc les apprentis sont concernés
mais il y a d'autres catégories et
notamment il y a une catégorie moi qui
me touche particulière non c'est ceux
qu'on appelle les aides familiaux et ces
aides familiaux on les retrouve dans
deux secteurs dans le secteur agricole
il y a eu énormément d'aide familiaux
agricoles dans ce domaine et puis bien
évidemment dans le domaine du commerce
également où on a vu bien souvent des
enfants de commerçants qui d'une
certaine façon avant de reprendre
l'activité parentale était dans des
conditions qui sont souvent un peu
floues qui qui apportait donc une aide
donc à la tenue à la tenue du commerce
donc est-ce que ces aides familiaux à
partir du moment où comment dirais-je
leur activité professionnelle serait
reconnue en termes de trimestre on la
possibilité puisque souvent ils n'ont
pas été couverts par une cotisation de
pouvoir procéder à le rachat puisque
c'est le terme qu'on emploie au rachat
de de ces trimestres
je trouve ses amendements intéressants
même si bon il est quand même question
de rachat de trimestre et on sait que
les rachats de trimestres coûtent cher
mais bon
c'est une fenêtre me semble-t-il
intéressante monsieur le rapporteur je
vous prends au mot
monsieur le rapporteur je vous prends au
mot
sur monsieur le rapporteur
je vous prends au mot effectivement sur
des amendements de fond voilà on peut
discuter et donc on discute c'est à dire
que si même on débat pardon on débat et
donc et donc comme je vous prends moi je
vous le dis sur des amendements comme
celui-là et comme celui de tout à
l'heure mon amendement sur l'histoire
des 5% de surcotte je ne comprends
décidément pas pourquoi l'article 38 a
été déployé parce qu'on était vraiment
sur le fond là aussi sur le sujet
oui
donc je mets au bois ces trois
amendements identiques
notre groupe votre âmement déposé par
notre collègue
lévriers nous pensons que c'est une
avancée et puisque souvent nous
expliquer qu'il faut augmenter qu'en
augmentant les cotisations on allait
nuire à l'emploi et à la compositivité
des entreprises comme si la baisse des
cotisations était le fin du fin de la
création d'emplois je vous rappellerai
que dans les échos de juin 2022 il nous
est bien expliqué que dans l'année 2022
il est a priori et ça a été confirmé
d'ailleurs après que les deux tiers des
200 000 emplois créés dit dans le privé
l'ont été en apprentissage et donc c'est
moins la baisse des cotisations que le
soutien donné à des emplois pour former
des jeunes générations qui aura résolu
ou en tout cas baisser le niveau du
chômage nous nous soutenons en tout cas
cet amendement
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues simplement
pour m'étonner un peu de
décrocher des ici maintenant sur
l'utilisation de l'article 38 là aussi
il suffira de revoir finalement ce qui
se passe dans cette assemblée pour se
rendre compte que ça fait un moment
qu'on est pour pas dire depuis toujours
sur le fond mais
monsieur Savary vous avez une pratique
amusante sympathique je me souviens que
depuis l'article 2 à l'article 2 vous
nous dites mais
avançons avançons parce que on va
traiter les sujets et on va les traiter
notamment à l'article 7 en disant tout
ça faut aller vite faut aller vite il
faut aller à l'article 7 et maintenant
que nous sommes à l'article 7 vous nous
dites pour aller vite faut aller à
l'article 8 bon voilà il y a une espèce
de de côté comme ça systématique nous
renvoyons nous renvoyant en permanence
au sujet quoi voilà donc je voulais je
voulais vous dire je voulais vous dire
que ce procédé il faudrait maintenant
l'arrêter je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que vous avez fait vous êtes fait un
honneur d'ouvrir très largement plus
qu'à l'Assemblée le temps de discussion
alors il faut quand même maintenant
l'utiliser ah voilà c'est pas la peine
c'est pas la peine d'avoir annoncé on
travaille jusqu'à dimanche soir pour
menacer les rétro vite et se retrouver
je sais pas désemparé vendredi par
exemple donc tenez
votre parole il faut aller au dimanche
soir on doit aller au dimanche soir
allons-y calmement et enfin dernier mot
je voudrais quand même féliciter notre
collègue pense et mange je crois qu'on
peut le faire parce que c'est le premier
amendement de cette partie de
l'hémicycle qui est bientôt je le crois
accepter on peut l'applaudir merci chers
collègues
le président bar
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président je ne méconnais
pas la force d'un certain nombre
d'arguments qui viennent de nous être
présentés
je suis moi-même un passionné de
l'apprentissage et je considère qu'il
est essentiel dans notre pays que les
jeunes
adoptent cette disposition d'esprit
essentiel qui consiste à choisir ses
études en vue du métier et à faire
l'apprentissage du métier en situation
de travail pour autant il me semble que
cet amendement dans la rédaction est
approximative
n'a pas été suffisamment étudié et en ce
qui me concerne je voterai donc contre
cet amendement et je suggère à tous mes
collègues de s'y opposer je m'y
opposerai en tout cas
fermement jusqu'à ce qu'on est plus
faire avancer la discussion pour
améliorer le contenu de ce genre
d'initiative
bon je vais je vais mettre au bois à
monsieur le ministre vous y
merci monsieur le Président juste un mot
pour répondre aux interrogations de
Madame Lubin et si il me le permet de
répondre et de dire un mot aux questions
bas d'abord pour dire que Madame Duba de
m'écoute pas d'abord dire à Madame
Dubach le dispositif pour ce qui
concerne l'apprentissage
fait que les trimestres travaillent en
apprentissage sont comptés comme cotisés
depuis 2013 parce que la rémunération
des apprentis a atteint un niveau qui
permet de les compter il a été prévu
dans la loi 2013 applicable à partir
2014 la possibilité d'un rachat rachat
autour de 1500 euros le trimestre ça
peut paraître beaucoup comme ça mais
cela deux caractéristiques c'est une
somme fixe pendant toute la carrière
alors que tous les rachats de trimestres
sont fondés sur une somme qui tient
compte d'une méthode actuelle et qui
peuvent atteindre 5 à 6000 euros si on
les rachète à la toute fin de la
carrière donc je dis que ça avantageux
parce que la somme fixe de 1500 euros
est valable tout au long de la carrière
par contre la prise en compte de ces
trimestres rachetés étaient prévus pour
ce qui concerne la durée de cotisation
requise pour avoir accès à une retraite
à taux plein sans décote mais pas pour
l'éligibilité au départ au titre des
carrières longues et donc ce que nous
faisons avec cet amendement ce qui me
proposait par les parlementaires en tout
cas c'est de permettre l'accès aux
dispositif de départ anticiper pour
carquérir longue sur la base de ces
trimestres rachetée sachant que quand on
ne changeons rien aux conditions de
rachat de 2014 et pour dire à Monsieur
le question bas que
que je tiens rassuré monsieur le
questemba il s'agit vraiment d'intégrer
donc cette trimestre racheté alors
qu'ils ont été réalisés dans le cas d'un
contrat d'apprentissage qui n'était pas
suffisamment rémunéré pour être
considéré comme cotisé dans le cadre des
trimestres retenus pour l'éligibilité au
départ entier pour les carrières longues
vous interrogez sur sa rédaction je peux
vous assurer monsieur le Kester que la
rédaction proposée par le parlementaires
reçoit l'approbation complète des
services du gouvernement
merci
la parole est au président malgré
merci monsieur le Président il a eu sur
cet amendement plusieurs orateurs qui
l'ont défendu un orateur qui s'est
exprimé contre le ministre et le
rapporteur se sont longuement exprimés
sur cette amendement je demande donc
l'application de l'article 38 merci
je suis saisi donc sur cette amendement
de l'application d'articles 38 le
président comptable
c'est l'un ou l'autre
merci
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président je suis je suis heureux que le
président maluré est enfin trouvé le
livre vert mais franchement franchement
l'article 48 ok vous avez fait une
découverte depuis hier soir ça c'est
rigolo 5 minutes mais quand même on est
en train de débattre sur des amendements
RDSE RDPI écologiste on est en train de
d'échanger
même il me semble que Monsieur
rapporteur a dit que c'était intéressant
on a eu des vrais des vrais échanges
même le président bat aussi intervenu il
me semble pour dire d'ailleurs les
doutes qui pouvaient avoir sur cet
amendement donc il me semble quand même
que ces échanges qu'on a eu ils sont
plus utiles ils sont plus ce qui est
intéressant donc moi je suis quand même
déjà sur l'usage de l'article 38 comme
vous le faites depuis hier soir qui est
totalement scandaleux mais le faire de
cette manière là sur des amendements sur
lequel on est dans une discussion
qu'est-ce qui change par rapport
un autre habitude et notre habitude
qu'on a ici de débattre de manière
sereine qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui
vous énerve aujourd'hui pourquoi vous ne
voulez plus de débattre qu'est-ce qui
vous qu'est-ce qui vous gêne dans cet
article 7 quelle est cette obstruction
quasi continuelle ça y est Monsieur
monsieur malloret a trouvé son livre
vert et maintenant il va nous faire des
articles 38 après article 38 c'est quand
même enfin comme donc franchement je
pense que vous pourriez encore retirer
qu'on puisse débattre et sereinement
pouvoir voter pour pouvoir voter ses
amendements qui me semble important en
plus on l'a dit c'était peut-être le
seul amendement de cette partie là de
l'hémicy qui pouvait être qui pouvait
venir peut-être quelque peu enrichir ce
texte quand même et en plus c'était un
amendement de Raymonde pourcemonge qui
quand même n'a pas ménagé sa peine
depuis le début de ce
depuis de début de ce débats
merci monsieur jaumier
merci
monsieur le président
président malgré
nous avons tous constaté que sur ces
trois amendements il y a eu des échanges
qui étaient il me semble terminé le
ministre s'est exprimé et je crois sauf
erreur qu'il n'y avait plus de demandes
de parole
votre déclenchement de l'article 38
amène chacun des groupes de l'opposition
maintenant à s'exprimer pendant le temps
qu'il aurait dévolu pour vous faire
remarquer que vous êtes en train de
tourner en ridicule l'application de cet
article vous êtes en train de le
tourner pure
il
n'y a vous ne pouvez pas
arguer de la moindre obstruction à
l'occasion de ces la discussion de ses
amendements à l'occasion de la
discussion de ces amendements donc si
vous êtes parti pour appliquer l'article
38 sur chaque amendement sur chaque
amendement il va y avoir des prises de
parole de nos trois groupes pour pointer
le fait que
pour pointer le fait que vous êtes dans
une application indiscriminée qui vise à
faire obstacle à la conduite des débats
moi j'appelle mais vraiment je vous
appelle à ne pas voter l'application
l'article 38 sur cette sésamendement là
et vous verrez qu'il n'y aura pas une
pluie d'intervention que en gros le
débat est épuisé il y aura peut-être un
collègue ou je ne sais pas ou deux qui
s'exprimera je n'en sais rien non nous
avons eu un débat apaisé et intéressant
le ministre a apporté des éléments qui
étaient intéressants et si vous ne
voulez pas de ce type de discussion
alors effectivement nous allons passer
quatre jours à des interventions
purement sur la forme qui vont là
n'avoir aucun intérêt vous avez la
responsabilité vous avez la majorité
vous avez des armes du règlement vous
avez aussi la responsabilité que la
conduite des débats soit apaisée merci
chers collègues madame Brulat
merci
monsieur le Président je suis un peu
frappé que notre collègue m'a luré qui
donne des leçons de démocratie à la
terre entière
soit choquée que chacun puisse défendre
ici quelques amendements je trouve que
le débat qui vient de s'engager
était d'un apport au débat global parce
que c'est la première fois à ma
connaissance que nous a que nous
abordons ce sujet de l'apprentissage moi
j'ai été particulièrement intéressé
d'entendre l'argumentation du de
Philippe Bas et je pense que ce sujet
mérite d'être approfondi
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que
l'Assemblée nationale détient désormais
le record de du nombre de 49,3 qui ont
été appliqués je crois qu'on en est déjà
11 est-ce que le Sénat veut s'engager
dans une concurrence
où il activeait l'article 38 bien
davantage encore j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire tout à l'heure j'ai entendu
pique pendre ici et parfois pour de très
bonnes raisons de la manière dont
c'était déroulé le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale
il faudrait pas me semble-t-il que ce
qui ressorte c'est que l'image du Sénat
donne la même mais si si mes chers
collègues si mes chers collègues c'est
l'image qui va rester parce que vous
savez nos concitoyens ils ne sont pas
férus comme vous de des articles du
règlement intérieur du Sénat ils sont
férus de débats démocratiques sur sur un
sujet qui engage leur vie et donc vos
procédures et vos manœuvres ils n'en ont
que faire ils veulent que nous
argumentions et que nous défendions les
uns et les autres comme il est légitime
de le faire nos options nos projets de
société sur des sujets aussi précis et
utiles que l'apprentissage merci chers
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le Président je ne
prendrais pas la parole sur l'article 38
mais je voulais saluer la vie favorable
de la commission et sortir un peu de ce
débat stérile parce que je pense que le
RDSE n'est pas dans une manœuvre
d'obstruction mais nous avons rendu peu
d'amendements et quand ils le sont c'est
vraiment pour améliorer nos articles
nous sommes regardés par beaucoup de
personnes concernées par cet article et
cet amendement spécifiquement nous avons
été sensibilité par sensibilisé par
beaucoup d'associations de personnes
handicapées qui sont concernées par ces
amendements donc j'aimerais que cet
amendement ne soit pas pris en otage
mais vraiment que nous puissions en âme
et conscience le voter parce que c'est
une mesure juste et au Sénat nous savons
peser sur ces mesures justes donc chers
collègues je vous demanderai
effectivement de pouvoir suivre
la vie favorable de la commission merci
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président Retailleau
ce qu'a proposé Bernard Chaumier c'était
très intéressant il a proposé que une
sorte d'antan pour qu'on aurait on
aurait pu se concentrer avec l'accord de
l'ensemble des groupes
sur ce qui constitue le coeur de la
réforme sur ce qui constitue l'essentiel
de nos intérêts c'est ce que le
président Gérard arraché vous a proposé
ce matin juste avant la conférence des
présidents messieurs les présidents de
groupes de gauche et vous avez refusé
parce que vous voulez faire de
l'obstruction parce que vous voulez que
le Parlement de votre part
l'obstruction c'est un parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri l'obstruction c'est la
négation du parlementarisme
l'obstruction c'est une prise en otage
d'une minorité sur l'ensemble de
l'institution
si
et nous vous obligez à recourir à
l'article 38 si chacun est raisonnable
si chacun discute au fond des articles
sans volonté d'obstruction alors oui
chacun pourra jouer le jeu mais la balle
est de votre camp écoutez
j'ai 11 amendements vous voulez que vous
voulez que je les lisser 11 amendements
4769 70 71 des amendements d'obstruction
et j'en ai d'autres par dizaines et par
centaines c'est ce que les Français
doivent savoir donc le 38 il est fait
pour neutraliser une manœuvre
d'obstruction la manœuvre d'obstruction
c'est la négation du rôle du Parlement
merci chers collègues
la parole est au président Patriat
j'écoute avec attention sans vociférer
sans interrompre et en essayant de
laisser l'opposition s'exprimer le plus
longtemps possible avec beaucoup de
patience et avec beaucoup d'acuités tu
le dis mais par contre il y a une chose
que je supporte pas mes chers collègues
c'est l'hypocrisie
parce que l'hypocrisie ça consiste à
dire ici on veut débattre de
l'apprentissage moi l'apprentissage
c'est un sujet qui me passionne les
sujets qu'on aborde maintenant son
passionnant qu'on puisse en débattre oui
mais le problème pour vous c'est pas de
débattre le débat c'est le faux prétexte
parce que ce matin j'étais en conférence
des présidents et j'ai entendu les trois
présidents des groupes d'opposition dire
clairement qu'il ne voulait pas qu'on
vote le texte au beau et ils l'ont dit
et ils l'ont dit donc nous faire croire
aujourd'hui qu'on veut débattre plus
qu'on veut toujours débattre plus tout
ça en fin de compte le débat plus il est
uniquement pour atteindre l'objectif
sont donnés celui de ne pas voter ce
texte se dessaisir se dessaisir de
pouvoir de voter la loi trouve sa
parfaitement hypocrite et je le dénonce
merci chers collègues
donc je vais mettre aux voix
l'application de l'article 38 qui est
pour l'application de l'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc l'article 38 est
adopté donc va être appliqué et donc
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe
écologiste sur les amendements
identiques
1895-1909 et 3403 avec deux avis
favorables il va être possédé donc ce
que tu as publique le scrutin est ouvert
voilà avec ce scrutin public que vous
vivez en direct sur l'antenne de public
c'est un public sur des amendements
concernant la prise en compte des années
d'apprentissage dans les carrières
effectivement pour cotiser et on voit ce
faux rythme qui se dessine avec des
discussions sur le fond de ces trois
amendements qui venaient du RDSE qui
venait également induire des pays et
également des écologistes et ensuite et
bien une prise de parole qui s'est
enchaînée sur les l'utilité ou pas de
l'article 38 qui vient contraindre les
débats et un quatrième utilisation de
cet articles 38 effectivement dans
l'hémicycle
344 contre 0 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
alors des amendements identiques
et en discussion commune trois
amendements identiques tout d'abord le
Sénat vient de voter un amendement dans
l'article 7 de la réforme des retraites
un article un amendement qui est comme
le disait Quentin concerne notamment les
personnes qui ont fait de
l'apprentissage les trimestres rachetés
correspondant à ces périodes
d'apprentissage pourront être désormais
avec cet amendement pris en compte dans
le calcul du dispositif carrière longue
voilà ça vient d'être voté par le Sénat
aussi pour compenser cette situation un
dispositif de validation de trimestre a
été mis en place en 2012 pour les
sportifs qui sont inscrits sur la liste
des sportifs de haut niveau le nombre de
trimestres maximales qui peut ainsi être
acquis et limiter à 16 soit 4 ans ce qui
correspond à une Olympiades avec cet
amendement on vise à porter ce nombre
maximal de validation de trimestre à 32
soit 2 Olympiades et par ailleurs il
ouvre également la possibilité sportive
de haut niveau de racheter des périodes
antérieures à 2012 ou des périodes
postérieure à 2012
merci monsieur le Président je pense que
c'est amendement devrait aussi faire
l'unanimité dans cette émission et comme
la rappeler Claude Kern donc cet
objectif c'est de permettre aux sportifs
au niveau inscrit sur les listes et
ministérielles de pouvoir donc étendre
ce dispositif à 32 trimestres et nous en
réjouissons il sera ainsi plus adapté la
durée moyenne des cailles à sportifs
c'est un moment propose également bien
sûr d'ouvrir pour ses athlètes le rachat
de trimestre et c'est une bonne affaire
par contre Monsieur le Ministre tous les
athlètes ne sont pas concernés par cette
mesure et certains qui ont jeunes femmes
et hommes qui ont brillé les couleurs de
la France sur les différents terrains
lors des compétitions olympiques et les
championnats du monde ne bénéficient pas
de ce dispositif je parle de tous ceux
qui étaient avant la réforme de 2012
donc aujourd'hui nous avons toute une
série d'athlètes qui se retrouvent
sur la réforme des retraites notamment
sur l'article 7 qui est reporte l'âge
légal de départ à 6 en France et la fin
de cette émission spéciale merci à
Quentin à calmer dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle d'avoir commenté ces débats
rendez-vous à 22h justement avec Quentin
Calmet pour suivre la suite des échanges
autour de cet article 7 article
essentiel de la réforme des retraites
très bonne soirée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
la séance est ouverte le texte arrive
derrière moi en séance à partir du 2
mars publics bouleverse son antenne pour
vous faire vivre en direct du 2 au 12
mars tous les débats autour de la
réforme des retraites au Sénat oui il y
a des solutions oui il y a d'autres
solutions en direct de l'hémicycle et
dans les coulisses du Sénat les
journalistes de la rédaction se
mobilisent pour vous aider à comprendre
jour après jour les étapes et les enjeux
de cette réforme majeure pour le pays je
demande des mesures plus fortes pour
l'emploi des seniors ça annonce des
séances houleuses je me sens impatient
monsieur les débats sur la réforme des
retraites cette en direct et en
exclusivité du 2 au 12 mars sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à manger c'est
beauté aujourd'hui en Normandie que les
plus connaisseurs auront reconnu
peut-être pas cette lumière changeante
entre les nuages mais en tout cas les
pommiers dans ce joli pré aujourd'hui
Agnès canaillé la sénatrice de
Seine-Maritime nous reçoit dans son beau
pays entre Seine et mer comme son nom
l'indique allez en route
[Musique]
ah j'étais sûr bonjour
Vincent
des conteneurs c'est incroyable il a été
mis en place pour les 500 ans de la
ville du Havre en 2017 et c'est vraiment
symbolique de notre belle ville
portuaire est-ce que c'est un endroit où
se trouve les amoureux ici oui
on se promène on va faire les amoureux
mais de la Seine-Maritime
alors vous vous êtes natif du Havre ah
oui moi je suis une adresse pure souche
comme on dit chez nous qu'est-ce que
vous faisiez dans la dans la vie profane
je fais des études de droit et puis je
collaborer aussi avec un parlementaire
Patrice Gélat c'était élu aussi du
territoire à vrai alors qu'est-ce qui
vous a mené à la vie politique parce que
évidemment juriste de formation passer
sans doute par le milieu associatif
peut-être d'Antoine ruffnac qui nous a
un petit peu poussé oui effectivement
appliqués dans ma vie professionnelle et
je rencontrais souvent des gens qui me
disaient tu diras Antoine ruchnak tu
diras
et donc moi j'ai dit bah écoutez
mesdames on va dire ensemble donc on
s'est réuni pendant trois ans on était
un groupe de femmes femme active
mobilisons-nous ensemble voilà c'était
notre allons-y et on a fait des
propositions Antoine Ruffenach de plein
de choses sur
le périscolaire les langues à l'école le
cul de la culture au Havre etc et puis
en 2008 en train de rester Acadie c'est
bien mesdames mais maintenant il suffit
pas de dire il faut faire donc venez
avec moi d'accord
une bonne partie du groupe dans son
équipe municipale en 2008 et entre les
deux vous avez pas eu envie de de la
députation qu'est-ce que vous a amené
vers le Sénat alors la députation j'ai
testé mais ils ont pas voulu moi parce
que c'était battue en 2012
oui bah c'est toujours se confronter
aussi fragile universel sur son propre
nom c'est toujours voilà un engagement
les siennes voilà on vend des
convictions donc et ça tout ce que
j'aime en politique c'est le concret et
c'est le contact avec les gens et donc
une campagne électorale c'est au moment
d'aller rencontrer les gens de pouvoir
discuter avec eux et puis deux ans plus
tard effectivement après le
renouvellement de l'équipe municipale
c'est là où Édouard Philippe a demandé
de me faire élire au Sénat en me disant
je ne connais rien au Sénat
débrouille-toi pour te faire élire
puisqu'on est devant le terminal des
croisières d'ailleurs ça rappelle que
c'était le départ du France vers New
York c'est la base des transatlantiques
ici mais aujourd'hui on va faire une
croisière en Seine-Maritime et oui on va
Fécamp je vous emmène vous êtes à la
barre c'est vous une capitaine allez
direction on fait quand
allez on quitte le port du Havre pour un
autre port historique la ville de Fécamp
à quelques kilomètres d'ici pour
rencontrer un pêcheur de coquilles
[Musique]